Hi everybody.
This is how we begin.
Ready,
set,
go.
The first part of the podcast is not required listening.
It's essentially commercials,
but occasionally it becomes entertaining.
In fact,
sometimes more entertaining than the actual podcast itself.
This is disturbing.
And as we're winging this entire thing and have no real program for how it's
supposed to run a,
we don't know what to say when that happens.
Sorry.
Oops,
I took the wheel to me.
Hits too,
too,
too many hands.
Well,
expect one of those shows,
ladies and gentlemen,
expect possibly a few oh Brian moments of this podcast brought to you by
kerosene games.
Um,
kerosene.
We're brought to you by a bunch of things.
Um,
but everything we're brought to you by,
we believe in that is our own 100% pledge.
We're never going to tell you dawg shit,
we're never going to sell you something that's not good.
We've been offered a lot of different things that we didn't agree with that
neither Brian nor I thought were interesting or just,
you know,
stuff that,
it just,
it just didn't seem like it was something that we should be endorsing.
So that's what we're trying to do.
We're trying to only endorse shit we would use and stuff we believe in.
And this kerosene games is a brand new startup and they have games that they're
developing specifically for iPads and four I iPhones and high end android
devices starting in February.
And what what it is is a lot of the games like especially like really high end,
big beautiful games,
a lot of them there,
they start out making him for consoles or they started out making them for a PC
and then they poured it over to an iPad.
That's not what these guys do.
What these guys do is they make bad ass games right out of the box for iPods and
touchscreen devices.
Um,
all you know,
the,
the various intuitive controls that they've put into these games they've put in
and designed for use with an iPad.
So it doesn't feel clunky at all.
The graphics are fucking awesome.
It's a really cool game and I've gotten nothing but positive feedback from
people that went out and bought it.
It's only three.
It's really cheap to 99.
I don't know why they say to you 99 not three bucks.
Stop playing with,
do they do that?
I don't want to save a penny of fuck.
Say $3 should three Oh one it says it's supposedly some psychological thing and
then you pass people that there.
We're just to the nation of pussies.
That's what it is.
Like one penny.
One Penny keeps you from fucking buying something.
Well,
can I get it for two 99 then I'll be happy with my purchase with $3.
I don't even know.
Is it worth $3 and just a nation of people poisoned by car smoke or something,
but not this mother fucker.
This blade slinger character.
He's like a bionic cowboy.
Um,
I don't know why they call him a cowboy because there's no fucking couch.
I guess I used to do is wear that hat and you're a cowboy.
This motherfuckers never seen a cow in his life.
How he got this guys,
the last thing from a cowboy,
you know what a cowboy is?
Cowboy is a guy who has to take these cows and move them in a certain direction.
It's the most boring ass fucking life ever.
He just run it around pushing cows.
That sort of real cowboy does.
Occasionally you have to last a one and it's a big day.
So when you were playing cowboys and Indians as a kid,
he does lassoed cows and stuff.
No,
I did you understand all always got killed.
I never understood that.
Stanwood cowboys really worth that.
The cowboys were like always fighting Indians in some sort of a fucking,
you know,
a Hatfield versus the McCoy sort of a way.
I didn't really understand what a cowboy was.
I was young when I did this,
my friend.
Anyway,
um,
it's kerosene games.
The game is played slinger and it's only three bucks.
The Fox and iPad eight inch is one of the coolest things in the road and playing
this game on it.
It's so,
it's so much better than a GameBoy nowadays.
Like it's like a game boy that's also a computer.
I mean,
it's great.
The graphics on this are amazing.
Yeah.
The,
I thought,
I thought the tablets were stupid as fuck when they first came out.
I was like,
this is,
but they're so convenient.
It's so cool.
And it's amazing how much you can store on them.
I mean that,
that hey,
oh yeah,
fuck.
What are you doing there?
Fell out.
It was very real.
Those,
it doesn't matter if it's real,
the tits.
Even if it's of your tits,
we can get in trouble.
It's art.
Is it?
Painting is painting of tests.
I still think we can get in trouble.
Uh,
we,
we are also brought to you by desk squad.
Dot.
TV does squad dot.
TV is the place where you can get the only place.
As far as I know,
we can get those,
a funky a tee shirts that,
that Brian makes the desk quad tee shirts.
It's a,
I don't know how to describe it other than a psychedelic cat with a suicide vest
on him.
For some folks,
you know,
it's really hard.
It's trying and trying and trying to draw the next one.
I'm in the middle of trying to draw the next one and it's,
it's hard to try to top,
yeah.
Now I feel like I,
there's like,
I'm stressed about
these,
if you're,
you dig these shirts too.
These are completely designed and produced by Brian.
So like you're not like getting,
you know,
he's not like hiring an artist to do it.
So you're,
you're actually getting his artwork.
So I need this room or something.
Maybe you need to not shroom,
take some coffee and joined the marines.
All right.
Anyway,
death squad.
Dot TV.
Go there and fun when the upcoming shows our cause.
Uh,
there's always,
there's always something going on in this wacky world and there's also desk
squad podcast network on iTunes where you can listen to the fabulous Kevin Perez
pointless,
which is up tomorrow.
Awesome.
One of my favorite podcasts and you can only get that off of death squad on
iTunes.
We are also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain and shroom tech and hemp force and all the shit that we
talk about on this podcast,
goddammit ad nauseum.
We also have this new dude who's onboard,
Dr Robert Lasar.
Apparently he's some super smart neurosurgeon and he's a big fan of Alpha brain.
Um,
if you are not,
you know,
there's a lot of people crying snake oil when it comes to anything that has to
do with cognitive function.
They're like,
wait a minute,
what is this?
What kind of nonsense is this?
Because there's a lot of stink.
Well,
going around ladies,
gentlemen,
Remember when people were selling those hologram bracelets?
Yeah,
and I love the people that's still wear them in Vegas.
This chick was telling me that they took the real technology from that bracelet
and they incorporate into their own,
but the,
that that bracelet was ripping people off.
But this shit works.
I go,
you got a Hologram?
Or like,
what is that?
Is that a Hologram?
Like what's it called?
W what are you calling it?
What do you call it?
You got a piece of plastic on your wrist if you believe it.
It makes you feel better.
A lot of how you feel is affected by your attitude a lot.
And if you truly feel like you've been gifted with this fucking rubber band
around your wrist,
that makes you move better,
you're going to start thinking like a person who moves better.
Cause that's a big part of what's fucked up about you.
All right,
Janet together bitches.
So,
um,
in in that vein,
I would be very sensitive to anything that I thought was a placebo.
The science behind Alpha brain is all rock solid.
You can look it up,
you can look up all the different various ingredients and the history of,
of human use of these ingredients,
including things like memory tests.
And there's,
there's a lot of shit that people have learned about the efficacy of nootropics
and,
uh,
the,
the weight of evidence clearly sides on the idea that vitamins and nutrients we
know affect human performance.
We know they affect your body's ability to recover your body's ability to be,
to be nourished in a way that allows it to move and function and operate at its
optimum levels.
I'm a big fan of supplementation.
I'm also a big fan of eating right.
I think that's one of the most important and underlooked things.
People just don't get enough fucking vegetables in their diets and uh,
one of the reasons we started selling these BLENDTEC blenders at [inaudible] dot
com is for that very reason to try to encourage people like you want to really
be healthy,
go to the supermarket as often as you can go three,
four times a week.
If you can get Kale and cucumbers and celery and garlic and,
and,
and get some sort of fruit like an apple so it doesn't taste like death.
Throw it in there with some coconut oil and rock that shit every morning.
You'll be a new human being.
You're just getting this just big wave of nutrients first thing in the morning
and then go about your day,
take some multivitamins,
take some protein supplements and get some fucking workouts in.
You can go get some kettle bells@onat.com and we even have a DVD you can follow.
Try to follow it.
You'll fucking puke.
It's the extreme kettlebell cardio workout.
It's brutal.
It's a brutal DVD.
I can't get through it with a 35 pounder.
I know dudes who can do,
it's crazy.
It's a crazy workout man.
And we sell that.
We sell everything to make you man the fuck up and your shit together.
And if you use a code name,
Rogan,
you'll save 10% off any n all supplements that um,
as for Mike,
my tee shirt,
a higher primate.com.
Hold on.
No I don't.
Um,
those t shirts,
uh,
they're,
they,
they're selling out faster than I can make them.
I'm sorry.
I I,
I appreciate that everybody's trying to buy him.
Um,
there's nothing I can do.
We put it in order and I've made a much bigger order this time.
So uh,
thank you for all the people that are buying them.
No,
it's higher-primate.com and I think most things are out of stock right now.
Sorry.
You fucks.
Look,
we got Steve Volk here.
He is an author about all things freaky and we're going to get down to business.
We're going to start this party as soon as Brian knows how to press that button.
Is it cause a visit
issue?
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
My man.
Thank you sir.
Steve Bulk.
Thank you very much man.
Thanks for coming down on me.
Fringe Ology is your book and Dude,
when,
uh,
Matt stags are a publicist,
um,
uh,
requested you or a suggested you.
I was so all over this cause this is like so right in my wheelhouse of shit that
I enjoy.
Um,
bullshit and stuff that might not be bullshit.
You know,
and there's a lot of both going around,
right?
There's a lot of bullshit folks,
don't get me wrong,
but it's not all bullshit.
There's some,
there's some weird shit out there in the world.
And does that mean hope there?
I,
I made a beep off my phone,
but there's a lot of people that almost immediately discount anything fringe,
whether it's psychics or whether it's,
uh,
you know,
I've gotten angry people over the last couple of weeks,
like angry emails and angry tweets because I suggested that something might be
going on.
When you think about someone and the phone calls,
the phone rings and it's them and that people like,
Oh,
you're attaching that to it.
This is a person you think about all day.
Like Sam Harris said some very logical points.
And I agree with him absolutely for the most part.
But there are specific isolated instances where you feel something and then
something happens where you know someone's looking at you.
Yeah,
yeah.
Remember at Sheldrake did a,
uh,
a controlled study in which he had people list for people who were present in
their lives.
Somebody who might in fact call them.
And then for,
I forget how long a period it was,
a week or two weeks,
something like that.
Um,
they were supposed to,
anytime the phone rang before they answered it,
think of which of these four people it was.
And um,
they thought of the correct person a more at a rate,
higher than chance,
significantly higher than chance.
And I don't have all those,
the,
the numbers in my head right now,
but it ended up being as statistically significant fact.
Right?
So instead of being a right when it was one of those four people,
one out of four times,
they were right far more often.
Wow,
that's interesting.
And Yeah,
well there's that because they knew that this one motherfucker just calls me all
the time and he's money in the bank.
I'm going to prove some psychics.
It's just one.
What if one guy just fucking calls you all day and you're like,
I know it's Marty and you pick it up and it's Marty because Marty calls you all
day.
I suppose it could be.
It could be that they had,
they had so many people involved in the study that it would seem to be what it
was,
is statistically significant effect in writing a book though.
Do you start looking for fuckery and studies like that?
And because you know,
of course your purpose initially was kind of did to disprove a lot of this
stuff.
And I have to tell you the chapter on telepathy in particular have scared the
hell out of me because I had gotten so used to hearing this skeptical line.
There's no evidence,
there's no evidence,
there's no evidence that I really expected to find weapons.
And,
um,
when I realized I was going to have to hang my ass out on the line and saying,
you know what,
there's actually some evidence.
Uh,
it was scary.
That was scary.
Was it scary because you thought like intellectually you'd be criticized and
you'd be marginalized.
Shore.
I thought it'd be ostracized within the profession of journalism,
you know,
for saying this.
But the fact is there's,
there's a really high level debate going on between really smart people about
the proper way to slice and dice these studies in terms of analyzing the
statistics that are generated.
And we can't at this point really be sure whether or not,
um,
sigh as they put it is that's the whole field of telepathy.
Whether or not cy exists,
but there's,
there's a lot of really strong evidence that would suggest it does.
And I,
and I mentioned this in my book,
a couple of the leading skeptics,
Chris French,
uh,
Richard Wiseman have both allowed that by the standards of any ordinary science,
telepathy is proven right.
So if,
if they were just judging kind of a pharmaceutical and looking at the same sorts
of numbers that these guys are,
are generating,
um,
they would say,
okay,
something's happening here.
Right?
There's a,
there's an effect.
But because it's a quote,
extraordinary claim,
uh,
we don't understand the physics of this,
what the mechanism would be that would allow for telepathy.
We need greater evidence.
And what,
when you say that it's been proven how so?
Well,
he's,
there again,
this is why he's been in French who I'm quoting,
but they would say that like,
say something like the Ganzfeld,
uh,
test if you're familiar with that.
No.
What does that,
okay.
The Ganzfeld test,
um,
they'll have a,
the,
there's many different ways to set it up,
right?
But one of the ways to set it up is you've got a person who is the,
um,
uh,
one of the sub test subjects that has,
have to ping pong balls,
put over their eyes,
right?
Um,
they have white noise being pumped into their ears and they're put into a very
comfortable chair where they're just sort of kind of suspended.
So there's very,
very little input into the system at that point.
And there are the receiver,
right?
And they're in a soundproof room,
so they're getting no normal whatsoever,
but they're supposed
to to just kind of go within,
right,
listen to themselves,
what thoughts occurred to them and start reporting back on what it is that
they're seeing in their mind's eye hearing in their mind,
that kind of thing.
And in another room,
uh,
the center is actually,
they're in a soundproof room,
two locked away from,
from the receiver.
They are looking at some sort of stimulus.
They're looking at an image on a computer,
um,
perhaps or you know,
photos in front of them.
And um,
they are trying to send that image to the person in the other room who they may
or may not know,
depending on the study.
And then there are there for target images that are then presented usually in
the best studies than an impartial judge will,
um,
look at a transcript of what the receiver said,
right?
And then they'll have four images in front of them,
one of which was the target that the center was actually trying to mentally send
to the receiver.
And you would expect that if the person with the ping pong balls over their eyes
got absolutely nothing,
then the judge would select the correct image one out of four times.
But instead you do enough trials and the men analyses on these,
when they crunch all the numbers from all the studies together and shows more
like a 32% effect instead of being right one on a four times,
they're right 32% of the time.
And this Wiseman and French would allow that.
These studies are generally well controlled enough that if this was an ordinary
claim that was being presented,
uh,
this was,
this is fine and we would accept this as evidence that something's up here,
some kind of information transfer.
The problem is because we don't understand the physics of how this would work,
they say we need greater evidence than this and they keep asking for greater and
greater levels of scientific controls to be put on the studies.
And they keep,
um,
just finding ways to kind of reject the result.
I've never been skeptical of the potential for psychic phenomenon,
but I've been very skeptical about almost every store that I've ever heard.
Unfortunately,
I've met a lot of fakers,
I've been a lot of fake psychics.
I met a lot of crazy girls and want to tell you they're like clairvoyant,
you know,
and people who are channelers and just,
there's so many looney tunes that are connected to it,
but a 32% increase sounds to me like probably what's real.
It's that I think that human average though,
when you think that would be about average,
if you were to do the same study with,
without having somebody trying to,
you know,
just the protein,
25% without it,
25% of 32%.
That's the idea.
So there's a small leap to seven.
Yeah.
Whatever it is,
chance.
But what's interesting in that 7%,
I mean,
if it's really statistically real,
if the study hasn't been fucked with the,
um,
the idea is that it's just a little bit,
right?
It was just a little bit,
the idea is that there's this weak signal that we're not normally picking up on.
Especially look at the way we live now,
where we're constantly,
uh,
constantly being bombarded by information and input and just stimulus.
But when you shut all that out and you close your eyes and you don't have any
sound that distracts you,
what's there?
Are you receiving any kind of accurate information?
And I'm,
I found the research really tantalizing.
And I also,
like I said,
I found it scary because I thought,
well,
here I am now I'm going to write that.
You know what?
When they tell you there's no evidence.
That's kind of bullshit,
right?
There's,
there's,
in fact there,
there is some evidence and the question is whether or not it's risen to the
level yet where we have to accept it.
Right?
Yeah.
It's a fascinating possibility that I think is inevitable.
I think it's inevitable either technologically or it's inevitable due to our own
bodies advancing and changing and mutation.
Because I feel like if you look at lower primates and you know,
they're,
they're very rudimentary language.
I think the chimps repeat certain sounds and they meet might mean certain
things,
but it's nowhere near what we can do.
And I've got to assume that this isn't the end.
This isn't the last version of the ape.
You know,
if,
if apes are going to continue to be successful,
this model's not going to stick around forever.
You could look at this one of two ways.
One way maybe we're evolving the ability right?
Another way,
maybe we're losing it,
right?
So back in the day when we were,
you mentioned before the sense of being stared at been some really good research
on this.
Again,
when the skeptics I mentioned Richard Wiseman did it,
did a study with a woman named Marilyn Schlitz where they collaborated and they
did three separate studies trying to figure out whether or not somebody could
sense that.
Some of us staring at the back of their head and they had realized controls on
it.
Why spin was part of uh,
you know,
the experiment.
Two out of the three times they did it,
they,
they got it again,
a statistically significant effect where people were right of,
you know,
far more often than chance would have suggested.
And if you think of it in an evolutionary sense,
which I do in the book,
right,
is that back in the day when we were being hunted all the time,
when we didn't have the kinds of fortifications we have now against the angry
packs of wolves that are out there and,
and,
uh,
we would have needed to have this ability to know that we're being stared at.
You know,
we would have,
it would have helped us survive as a species.
Yeah.
It makes sense.
Especially,
you know,
when you consider there's gotta be some pretty intense focus when a Predator
locks on you,
you know,
and that if there is some sort of a psychic bond out there between entities,
like the feeling like this motherfucker is about JP,
that's what it should fricking kick in.
Right.
Does you know what if they can feel it?
You know,
I think that there's probably a lot of senses that we lost in our separation
from the,
the natural world to here.
Just intuitive senses.
The army has done some research on
um,
intuition really and,
and who their most intuitive,
intuitive people are.
And it's the Co these people are the ones that they'll sort of look at to notice
when there's a hidden explosive device on the ground in Iraq.
Right.
And they've found that that to two groups in particular,
I think there was a third,
but there's two.
What I was remember that,
that are really good at this um,
hunters and uh,
people from the inner city.
And so suburbian milky people are fucking useless apparently.
So I knew that was the problem.
Everybody a break about it from the point of view of the person in the inner
city,
they've got to be aware of their entire environment and the potential for
danger.
And they've got to get used to honoring that impulse that something's a little
off here.
I need to respect that,
you know,
in order to stay alive.
And so the people who are best at finding these hidden explicit devices just can
tell it something just feels off in this area.
And then they start focusing in on what really,
well,
I didn't know,
first of all,
that the army actually used intuitive people to try to find bombs.
Keep,
keep,
keep in mind,
this is not about,
um,
psychic ability,
right?
It,
at least they're not talking about it in that context.
The army has done remote viewing,
uh,
research,
all that stuff in the past.
But you know,
this is,
this is a very straightforward intuition.
You can somebody who can just very,
very aware of their surroundings,
very aware of what's around them and alert to something that just seems wrong in
the environment.
That's not necessarily psychic at all.
Um,
but it's real and it,
and it,
but it hearkens back to that a little bit.
That idea is psychic though.
I mean,
you can just have some spidey sense.
Well,
I think that they're,
I think they're telling a lie,
you know,
I think they're toeing the line there.
Right up on that line where spidey sense and Taco spidey senses right where we
should be.
But the language they're using is,
is clearly very,
um,
you know,
hardcore have a dream.
This is something that I've always wanted to ask someone like you have police
really used psychics to find victims or any of that stuff?
Was any of that stuff ever really panned out?
I,
I've actually done a lot of police reporting in my past as well as,
you know,
this book.
I mean it's kind of generally,
I read about cops,
crime courts,
politics,
that kind of thing.
I spend a lot of time with cops and there's one homicide detective I know who
had absolutely it just,
and he's actually a religious guy,
which is sort of interesting.
He hates psychics.
They have,
they have led him on so many or tried to lead him on so many wild goose chases.
They screw with him when he's in the middle of a tough homicide investigation.
He's getting phone calls sometimes when it was higher.
UPS will be,
maybe you ought to listen,
maybe you gotta hear this out.
You know,
he cannot stand them.
But I recently met and I've really,
I've got to follow up with this guy.
Um,
and I haven't yet,
but I met a retired
homicide detective who told me he wanted to talk to me because he has worked
with a psychic who gave him good actionable information on multiple occasions.
And I haven't had a chance to,
to sit down with Pankaj yet.
I bet it was bone or trying to promote a business.
I know how that works.
That's what he was doing as an old guy.
I'm not sure he's both.
He's got to do what he's gotta do.
You know,
chick's got a psychic business.
I touch to keep the lights on this day and age.
I've always wanted to know.
Um,
I've heard a lot of people talk about it,
but everybody that I've heard talk about it hasn't researched it.
You know,
it hasn't,
it's not everybody wants to say,
you know,
psych,
they've used psychics to find bodies.
I'm like,
have they,
have,
they really,
I don't know if they have,
you know what Joe,
there's a couple of cases that are still sort of tantalizing out there that
would,
maybe something happened,
you know,
maybe,
maybe they didn't get actual information.
But for the most part,
if you even watch the psychic investigators show,
what's really sort of funny about it is that even when they're saying,
you know,
that this information was so valuable,
usually if you're really paying attention,
it's not actually the information that broke the case.
It's,
it's information that after the fact seem to fit.
And,
um,
so I'm still,
you know,
I'm still,
I'm still skeptical and everything,
but I'm skeptical of the psychics helping detectives.
But I'm really open to it because again,
if this,
if there is this sort of weak signal out there,
you know,
that occasionally we pick up on,
well then maybe sometimes it provides actionable information.
Do you remember this psychic friends network?
Yup.
Do you remember what show it was?
A Dionne Warwick or Warwick and Dionne Warwick are caught with weed at the
airport as what made her psychic.
Yeah.
That's what we should make to asshole.
She was working with.
When you,
I think when you smoke pot you get a little more kick there.
You make that a quote.
Go ahead.
I just to discredit me,
take it in context though.
I think you,
you become super sensitive and in,
in that that like you become very aware of,
people are creepy very,
where people are angry,
very aware of weird tension.
You know,
it makes it like really sensitive.
It makes you really aware of bad acting too.
It's tough to get high and watch some bad acting like Whoa,
you're fucking faking it.
And that is sort of like what,
what acting really is,
is the,
the best actors can lock into a role so deeply that they almost must believe it
in themselves because they're convincing you,
even though you know it's Daniel Day Lewis,
you know,
you know he's not really an Irish boxer.
You believe it cause he's,
he's tricked you.
He's,
he's bypassed all of your psychic energy.
But when you're high and you watched someone faking the funk,
just going through the,
you're like,
oh,
what are you doing up there?
Like you see them acting.
It's just rude.
It's disgusting.
It'd be interesting to watch it early and later Deniro in that context.
Yeah.
You're so right.
Is there ever a guy who's fallen so far for grains?
It's so sad.
Meet the Fockers really to fuck you to whatever the number two was.
Little Fuck,
we fucked you again.
Those little fuckers are bad.
I mean,
I'm not even saying that that's a bad movie,
but it's just like,
that's Robert Deniro,
you know,
and he's doing some new movie now with Lnr,
although are they get in a fight with each other or Alan Arkin rather?
It's just like he was in that movie.
We play like a wizard and shit.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
What was the movie with Robert De Niro?
Played like a wizard wizard.
It was like a really bad,
like the Hobbit type movie.
It looks so stupid.
I was like,
Robert,
what is going on?
I guess after a while you're like,
fuck it.
I did my time.
I feel I did my Goodfellows.
I did my raging bulls.
I'm just from here on in and have some fun.
Yeah.
I think about what he did for Cape Fear and he,
he was fucking incredible on a wait for a raging bull.
I mean,
you know,
too much sacrifice.
He's a taxi driver and he said just a fucking tremendous actor just in his prime
and his youth.
He was just unstoppable.
The deer hunter,
I mean,
my God,
that was a fucking movie.
He did some incredible,
incredible shit,
but the stuff he's doing now,
Barb,
Robert,
sad,
sad to see man,
it's fucked.
I'm sure he's feeling really sad right now.
Getting that Betty is that he's not as nearly as happy
busy was during the raging bull days when he was just creating something fucking
magnificent.
You know,
I think tiff,
he got into with JC watts.
Robert De Niro got a tiff with Jay Z.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
How is that possible?
She was apparently a trying to Phelan Jay z to talk about some sort of
entertainment event that was going on in JC.
Didn't call him back.
And so de Niro in public kind of dressed him down for it.
Wow.
That's,
yeah.
And I thought that's a little much,
you know,
I wonder if that one was just too busy too.
You know,
Bobby de Niro calls you,
you call them back.
Well,
how about maybe didn't really know it was you,
you know,
if it's Bobby,
Bobby Genero,
what if he got the hoe phone number or something we checked or would have Jay z,
you see that wizard movie and was like,
what the fuck Bobby Dinero,
what's you two inside?
You Owe me 20 bucks
or what if just hanging out with Robert Deniro was just uncomfortable for us
upon smoker.
Like if he,
like he just wanted to hang out all the time.
I kind of fucking,
Robert Deniro was coming over,
right?
Yeah.
What if,
what if he's like studying you?
Yeah.
You know,
like,
and he went to drink wine with you?
Yeah.
As a character actor,
he's studying you thinking if he could play you in a movie,
he starts rubbing your feet and Bobby didn't you?
Okay.
As Brian Red Ban red band in the future,
that would be him,
Robert De Niro as red band in the future.
It's you and like 50 years and you see
still,
you would probably do that role.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You still partying it up,
still talking like you're 12,
but now it's creepy cause you're like almost 60.
And everybody's like,
what the fuck is he going to grow up?
Nope.
Stop Rolling up.
It's Bobby de Niro as red band in his sixties.
That's a good idea for a movie.
It is.
No,
it's not.
So don't make that.
So what,
what subject did you get started with?
What led you to just pursue this,
uh,
the,
um,
the storyline in this book or the idea of won in this book of just chasing down
all things French.
There were a couple of things that,
and that motivated me.
Um,
one of them was a family goes story I grew up with as a kid,
um,
where supposedly our house,
these are my red band notes by the way,
in.
And as you're noticing this,
I'm going to,
I'm an avid listener of the show and I know he might say totally random shit
that will totally distract me.
And if you guys don't want to be able to take a note on where I was,
it's good.
Move the car.
We should have it for you.
You're far,
definitely guess captain flow record.
So I um,
I grew up with a ghost story,
a ghost that was supposedly in my house.
This stuff happened when I was five or six years old,
so I have very fragmented memories of it,
but it was a,
um,
it's really sort of starts with the cliche.
It was a thing that went bump in the night,
only at bumped.
It thought it,
it boomed.
Uh,
it happened only at night.
I would go on for tens of minutes at a time.
It sounded like it was coming from somewhere upstairs.
So my parents and the first floor thought it was on the roof of the house.
My brother and I on one side of the house,
thought it was on the roof over our heads,
my sisters in their room.
I did not share an adjoining wall with us.
Thought it was on the roof and or in there up the high in the walls.
And um,
at first that's what it was.
It was this noise,
but it was so loud.
It would wake everybody up and it would go on for awhile.
And my parents hunted for a prosaic explanations.
Um,
didn't fit with like a water hammer or anything with the plumbing.
It didn't fit with the house settling because of how long it went on.
And you have an addict or was it just a roof?
No attic.
And um,
my sister started reporting stranger things.
It's really movie shit.
Right?
They started reporting that,
um,
their bed frames would shake in the middle of the night and wake them up.
A claim that they saw a woman walk right through the room.
Um,
you know,
literally eight ghost,
right.
My parents,
and I find this really important.
My parents set that aside and discounted it for a couple of reasons.
It was coming from kids and who would want to believe that that's true.
I mean,
I think one of the things the skeptics always do is say,
you know,
it's sort of wishful thinking and superstition that people hear a noise and they
leap to ghost.
But my family didn't.
And so they spent nine months or a year trying to recreate the noise and various
ways trying to figure out what it was.
And when my sisters would tell these crazy stories,
they were just kind of like number one,
they didn't want to believe it.
Who wants to believe your starters are being terrorized at night.
Right.
Something going on in their room.
But finally,
and I was raised Catholic and we hadn't fallen out of the church yet.
That was still coming.
But um,
my dad went to the family priest and he told him what was going on cause he'd
run out of other answers and the priest said,
you know,
usually cases like this,
which I always find that language interesting as well because it implies he does
this on a fairly regular basis.
Usually in cases like this,
I come over and I blessed the house.
So he came over,
and I remember this vividly because to have father Crowley come into the,
uh,
come into the house with the vestments on,
in swinging,
um,
like the incense around and praying and Latin was intense,
right?
As a kid.
Um,
I said like,
it was like six.
He was,
he was God himself,
you know,
standing up on that pulpit and he comes in our house,
he's swinging incense around and when he leaves and he says to my dad,
uh,
so long,
Jerry,
I'm sure everything will be fine.
But that night actually things got worse.
The booming went on longer and louder than ever before.
And for the first time it seemed to locate in a specific spot.
So instead of coming from this sort of Amorphous area,
somewhere up on the roof,
it hits at the top of the stairs,
the landing,
and then it came downstairs like one step at a time.
My father said it sounded like a kid throwing a tantrum and when it hit the
bottom floor,
um,
they could feel the floor shake under their feet.
My parents,
and we never heard it again.
And so I grow up with this story and I think of it as a,
you know,
for a long time,
all the way through adolescence.
It was just sort of thing.
Um,
I don't know,
man,
an article of faith,
like I didn't even question it.
It,
it just was,
but you know,
you get into college,
then you start meeting other people and you start getting familiar with critical
thinking.
You're like,
the hell is that.
You know,
what the hell was that?
That's not how old were you when this was going on?
I was about six.
And so whenever memories I have it are very fragmentary,
but I gotta tell you,
Joe and I asked my parents about it for the book and I actually interviewed
them.
I knew someday I was going to write about this.
Right.
I interviewed the many years before I really settled on,
this is the book I'm gonna write.
And I actually sat down and I recorded it and I will never forget when they were
describing that last night when it came down the stairs,
they turn white,
they held hands across the table.
They were still frightened.
Just by the memory of it.
So for them,
whatever it was was tremendously real.
And I wanted to explore that and see what we could,
there have been anything strange there could they have possibly somehow and in
my brothers and sisters do could we,
all of us somehow imagined all this.
And so that was part of my inspiration for the book.
What is your conclusion on that?
Do you,
do you look back?
I mean,
I don't remember anything that happened when I was six that I can tell you
reliably what really happened.
I have just a few that's Jews.
Sure,
sure.
And that's true of,
of uh,
generally of,
of,
of people.
I mean it's very hard to trust childhood memories.
I'm not sure I should trust my own memories of that event.
That's another thing that's sort of kind of disassociated me from it makes it
hard to now 43.
Yeah.
When you look back at six,
I mean,
how much do you really,
how much do you remember if sex actually have a creepy amount of memories?
From my childhood?
Yeah.
But a legit,
well that's the question I need to,
but I don't know how legitimate they did this.
A great psychologist,
child psychologist,
uh,
did a lot of studies on this.
And one of the things he pointed out in his,
in his own life,
he,
he had this very vivid memory of being kidnapped because he was told he was
kidnapped.
And then years later,
the person who was supposedly the witness to the kidnapping admitted that they
made the story up.
And so he had this really shocking,
vivid memory through his whole life.
I forget at what point it was revealed to him and it wasn't true.
So that's how much we can be deceived by these things.
And you asked the conclusion I came to,
and I think it's very healthy conclusion.
The conclusion I came to is,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Right.
And there's still mystery there.
None of the normal prosaic explanations work for me.
Right.
It was not a water hammer.
It was,
it was not.
No,
it was not a rat making a noise.
That pig.
It was not a a plumbing problem,
you know,
it was not the house settling.
Do you remember it being really loud?
Really loud.
Like someone slamming a door or something like that at loud.
Loudest like a sledge hammer getting,
getting a weld at its loudest and so you go outside and there's no one on the
roof.
Yeah.
Funny story there.
And My,
my parents cause I was so,
I was so young and I remember this,
this one,
I know this fricken memory is true.
I remember them taking me outside at night because we were scared to show me,
show me that there were raccoons dumping on the roof because it was nighttime
and this was the story that gave their little kid.
Oh honey,
it's just raccoons jumping up and down on the roof.
And I was young enough that I was like,
okay raccoon sometimes dope up,
down on the roof.
Who though?
I mean if they suppressive,
they're fucking,
you know,
girls would fight back some gangster shit going on,
gangs,
raccoons and turning it down on your roof.
Not enough of them.
It was an ally.
Many nights.
Yeah,
and too many nights,
man.
I mean tens of minutes at a time.
Raccoons are just bouncing up and down on your roof was like the octagon for the
ultimate fighting championship when you're sleeping.
That would be nice to get out in the middle when you open the door and they just
get,
goes through his climb up the trees and hard.
There's the crafty,
those fucking raccoons.
I would have set up cameras everywhere.
I would have figured that shit out too.
Long time ago though.
Yeah,
I would.
I'd put everything in 1975 in 1975 we weren't walking around with these HD
cameras.
That vision,
I get courtroom sketch artist,
he's just put them on every corner of the house.
Courtroom sketches is the dumbest thing ever that they still have to use someone
to sketch what's happening.
You can't take a picture.
It's the beauty of it.
What does that mean?
It's like we're not supposed to be able to see inside the sacred courtroom where
the decisions are being rendered.
So instead,
here's an artist's depiction of the action.
The fuck are you showing me drawings for?
You know he can show it to me or you can't.
Is that the a real guy at the table?
That's what he looks like.
That's the drawing represents what he looks like.
Right.
Show me a fucking picture.
Stupid.
Okay.
My game,
when we plan a flash would be distracting.
Is that what it is?
How about no flashes?
Yeah,
it seems pretty easy to just do no flashes.
You know,
it's shutter clicks.
Even weirder.
Someone's fucking staring at you and drawing you.
That's even weirder,
man.
Imagine,
you know you're talking about your,
your experience and trying to tell the truth,
the whole truth and nothing but,
and some fucking Weirdos.
I ball in you and drawing your face.
That's gotta be a little mind fuck.
And it would be probably affects your decision making skills when you're in
court.
Actually,
it's fucking true.
If the cameras are a lot easier to handle that as somebody who was sitting here
drawing some asshole using outdated technology and could be get here on a horse,
he'd be taking license with my image to yeah,
he got there on a horse.
All his books are written in script.
We have courtroom sketch room artists for that show that I do.
They have,
they draw during the whole con uh,
live podcasts.
The secret show thing.
That's hilarious.
Like here's the Ari,
let's think the thing that's a good idea
and we sell it in the artist's gets all the money.
No,
it's a good idea.
That's a way better idea and use it in court.
See we found a new use for those people and I'll have to do that anymore.
No,
this is too though.
So as the years went on and I would share that story,
I stopped sharing it.
Right.
Because I was starting to run into more and more people who were totally
adamantly opposed,
not,
not only oppose the idea of ghosts,
I'm pretty suspicious about the idea of coast.
Right.
They were adamantly opposed to the idea that,
that there was even a mystery there.
And so that's kind of what I hold out for in the book,
that sometimes we just need to be able to admit.
I just say the words,
I don't know what happened.
People want to rush to some kind of conclusion whether they have enough evidence
or data or not.
And I ran into people over the years who would insist it had to be a water
hammer even though it doesn't fit.
Uh,
you know the story at all.
What is a water hammer?
That's when the water's Donk,
donk,
donk.
Again,
it has that crazy noise that I used to live in apartment
building.
He heard that a lot.
Yeah.
Sudden flow of water stops and then you get that sound because the energy,
the water buildup is converted to caustic energy cause it's gotta go somewhere.
Oh,
that's what it is.
And it doesn't,
it doesn't last that long.
And it doesn't make that kind of noise.
And it sounds like,
it doesn't sound like it's coming from your,
your roof or last tens of minutes.
And it certainly never locates on the steps,
but this is all when you were six.
Yeah.
So,
so in the end you kind of have to trust it or not,
right?
That's the question you're left with.
Do I trust my mother and father's account,
my sister's account,
my brother's account,
and you know,
on somewhat on someone like do,
but can I really buy into the idea that there are ghosts?
I mean,
so one of the things I explored,
and I,
I find this really interesting,
I mean there are people out there working with,
um,
sort of other,
uh,
other technologies to determine if maybe there's an abundance of electromagnetic
energy in the air in certain areas,
then it fucks with your temporal lobe.
Then you have drilling.
I mean,
where,
where was this that it was in Pittsburgh maybe.
And I'm not a lot of fault lines.
I don't think they're all others occasional or is that one in Ohio that they
just found out that we're making the earthquake happened,
something that happened,
something.
And,
um,
a guy working with infrasound,
uh,
getting Vic Tandy did research and infrasound.
It's a level of sound beneath even the range of human hearing,
but it actually has an effect.
It can create a sense of pressure and an easiness in your chest.
Uh,
it actually can even impact sort of the eyeball,
the actual vibration in the air and cause you to see a cloudy shapes when there
aren't any.
I don't think any of those concerns clearly explain,
uh,
what ha whatever happened in my house either.
But what I like about it is at least,
at least here somebody is thinking creatively and not thinking so poorly of
their fellow human that they just,
yeah,
you heard a creaking floorboard and you jumped to a fucking ghost because you're
that stupid.
And that's a superstitious it,
these sorts of explanations,
I think grant people the proper dignity to be,
uh,
that they're reporting things at least somewhat accurately write something
really unusual was happening.
It's,
um,
it's a very unfortunate reality that we live in that I can't trust anybody to
tell me like what really happened.
Sure.
So when you,
when a legitimate event,
if the legitimate event occurs,
it's immediately dismissed.
If you really looked at how many strange things exist both in the natural world
and in the,
uh,
just the,
just the world of space,
just the world of dark matter and supernovas and all those things are way
crazier than ghosts.
Okay.
A ghosting shit compared to the sun.
You know what I mean?
The idea that we're living in a multiverse,
that there's an infinite number of us having this conversation right now and
then something that is life exists at all that you can see with eyeballs,
you know,
that is just as freaky as something that used to live,
but its essence in some form stays for some reason.
I think the idea that this dimension that we live in is super concrete and you
know,
just cause you can hit it with a fucking balled fist and push it into a street
and watch a car slam into it.
But when you're dealing with real solid objects and that's all there is here,
I told him necessarily by that I don't,
I don't,
I don't believe in most of what I hear in terms of psychics and psychic readings
and ghost stories.
I think most of it's bullshit,
but I think it's very possible that something remains of you and that you're not
just skin tissue and bone tissue and blood and more than me.
Yeah,
there might be something going on and that something might leave your body and
exist in some other state and almost an enact assessable environment that's
parallels us.
And that's not outside the realm of possibility.
It sounds so woo woo,
but it's not.
It's not because life itself,
the,
the whole idea that your,
your body is just this big chemical reaction and electromagnetic and
oh that's crazy.
Neuroscientists can't yet answer the basic question of how consciousness is
produced.
Right?
So how we get from the physical stuff of the brain to nonphysical subjective
experience is a complete and total mystery.
And yet it is the thing that really defines our lives,
our internal experience of the world.
And there is no explanation for it.
Like how scientists get to what's,
what part of the brain does what?
Like this guy got an injury here.
So that removes this part of the brain that removes his ability to do this.
He's got an injury here.
So,
well now we know that this,
this inhibits walking and this is where,
you know,
your eyesight is dealt with.
But what they can't figure out is where's the thinking person with morals and
ethics and love?
Where's he in there?
Is he just a crackling?
Is he just the energy that makes all those cells fire where she,
where's the girl who can,
you know,
who can enjoy the things that she enjoys and,
and enjoy the food that she can do is where,
where's all that?
And there's something else to consider too,
Joe,
is that,
okay,
so we get these damage to our brain and we'll lose certain faculties.
Sometimes we only lose them for a certain time,
right?
Because of neuroplasticity.
These things come back online and where an or other parts of the brain simply
pick up those functions.
And this is easier to do when you're younger than when you're older.
But,
um,
the thing that fascinates me are people who will lose their memory for a certain
time and then those memories begin to come back.
And this is a,
again,
a relatively common thing.
Sure.
How,
how does that happen?
Where were the memory is stored?
Where did they go and they were gone?
It's a very good question and it's one that happens when people get concussions.
There's a concussions cause a great deal of short term memory loss.
It's out of the,
uh,
actually looked at this a little bit in the book.
I mean doctors will assess how severe a person's injury was by,
uh,
coming up with a degree of memory loss.
Like asking them,
what's the last thing you remember before the injury?
What's the first thing you remember after the injury?
And the,
the longer the blank period,
the more hurt you are.
I looked at near death experiences in the book and that's,
so that's one of the things that you mean there because what's,
what's weird about these guys is that in girls is they oftentimes come back with
a totally flowing memory of an event that should have knocked their memory,
producing capabilities offline for a certain amount of time.
And yet somehow didn't seem too,
um,
and I'm,
I'm okay with saying like,
like within your death experience,
I take a lot of flack really from both sides because believers will contact me
and say they're upset that I won't come out and say that,
you know,
the near death experience is smoking gun evidence that there's an afterlife.
Uh,
you know,
I don't think it is smoking gun evidence that there's an afterlife,
but I also don't think it's yet been explained.
And,
and again,
we end up back in this place where everybody wants to act like they know
everything.
Everybody wants to push everything into a conclusion.
I think the most rational thing to say is we,
we fully understand that
experience.
Yet,
you know,
in the near death experience,
it has to be related to what you're,
you're on brain can produce as far as psychedelic chemicals.
It has to be your own brain produces the most potent psychedelic drug known to
man.
And why wouldn't it produce that shit if you were going to die?
If you're in high stress periods,
if you're freaking,
if it's,
this is the end,
your body thinks this is it,
we're going to die and then it comes back,
you know,
you,
you've very likely could have come back from a psychedelic trip as well.
Well,
let me tell you,
I'm just going to cut straight to the chase.
The best evidence that the MD has to provide.
Okay.
This is the Best Janice minor holding a researcher did a study where she went
through all the medical literature and all the research that's been done in
India,
you so far and she tabulated,
um,
veridical perceptions,
so accurate and true perceptions that people got wow quote out of body.
And what she came up with is that,
um,
out of 38 cases in the medical literature where people were able to recount what
was going on in the room when they were flatlined or above the table and all
that stuff of stuff,
right when they were in this sort of severe physical distress,
35 of them were accurate and every detail they reported,
two of them had minor errors.
This sort of errors I'd have,
you know,
if I was trying to describe what I had for breakfast today,
I mean,
I might miss something and then one person was just totally off the freaking
reservation.
Right.
One person who is just,
she totally wrong about everything.
Um,
but 30 what was the,
what was funny about his team or her?
You know what,
I haven't,
I haven't read all the details of what they said,
but it was,
I mean,
they were just off on everything.
I,
no idea what machines were used.
They had no idea how many people were in the room had been an incredibly
accurate,
35 of them were accurate count of how many phones?
38.
Oh my God.
In their entirety.
Now the skeptical response to this is that the researchers themselves sort of a
quote,
you know,
would have suppressed information that wasn't accurate because they were so
blown away by what they were hearing that they went ahead and,
um,
only recorded sort of positive responses because the negative ones weren't
making any impact with them or weren't landing with them.
And the other,
uh,
the thing I'll propose is that,
well,
um,
maybe
pretty serious accusation and why,
why would they say that they have the questions and as all the,
everything's been recorded,
of course,
uh,
you know,
we'd have to go back through every last study to figure out what,
what research materials they had in every case.
But I mean,
that's just one,
one objection.
They lodge any other objection in lounges that,
well,
maybe they had some sort of anesthesia awareness,
right?
The Pr,
if the person wasn't anesthesia,
sometimes you're still aware of what's going on in the room.
Um,
so they'll,
they'll log that one in there too.
Or they'll,
they'll say that,
um,
uh,
they call it a PR profusion level of blood to the brain.
Maybe they were getting cardiac massage and that does supply a certain amount of
blood to your brain.
So maybe,
uh,
some part of the brain was still operating and able to retain a certain amount
of information,
but it just,
it's,
these are possibilities.
These are ideas
that maybe explain it,
but 35 out of 38,
that's it.
It's,
it's remarkable and it's enough to push it into an area.
And we have to say,
you know,
maybe something is going on here.
I mean,
do you ever feel in a psychedelic experience that you get accurate information,
not just stuff that your mind is coming up with,
but some sort of signal or contact with something that's quote real?
Will you believe that whether or not it's happening is the big debate,
right?
You know,
there's people that absolutely believe that they're in contact with entities and
there's other people that believe that you're just accessing the,
the,
the imagination and the mind is interfacing with distortion of its visual
abilities in massive form and you're putting context to that and trying to make,
make like rational understanding of it.
One of my favorite stories in the book,
um,
I,
when I was researching and near death experience,
I look pretty deeply in the story of Elizabeth Kubler Ross who wrote the book on
death and dying,
which kind of galvanized the whole hospice movement and made end of life care in
this country and really around the world.
A lot more humane.
And she is one of the first people ever to encounter the near death experience
and she did it before that phrase was even coined.
I mean it was Raymond Mooney wrote the book in 1975 she in the 60s was running
across patients in the hospital ward.
She was a psychologist who are telling these same kinds of stories and when I
find really a couple layers to this when I get to you,
but what's really fascinating is she wanted to reject this stuff at first,
completely her research partner,
the reverend,
while I'm,
we will Amara,
who is really terrific dude,
I loved interviewing this guy.
He's still around.
He was a reverend and he had been appointed to sort of go along on the hospital
wards with her.
What she was doing is very controversial.
Nobody talked to the terminally ill at that point.
They were the sort of shunted off to the side and so the fact that she was doing
this was was really angering.
A lot of the hospital staff.
So the administration put this reverend with her as a way of saying it,
kind of giving her their blessing as a way of saying she's,
it's,
she's not her alone.
Right.
There's,
there's somebody with her and I would imagine Ramaro was pretty formidable,
so nobody wanted to fuck you over tomorrow because I met the guy,
he's awesome.
But anyway,
one of the early stories they encountered before they started even researching
this experience because they'd hear these stories and kind of blow them off
because they didn't know what to do with them.
Finally,
he's out near the elevators.
One day a woman goes into cardiac arrest.
He,
she's resuscitated right.
Right there in the hall,
you know,
they went to work on it or they resuscitated her.
He goes to see her later and she starts describing the scene of what happened.
Exactly.
And she even describes that she was able in this stuff sounds ridiculous.
Right.
But she was able to float in at one point behind a resident who was taking notes
because one of the things they did with,
you know,
if you've got an inexperienced doctor on the scene like that and there's an
emergency thing going on,
they generally just don't
just take notes on what's going on.
It's a way of giving them something to do and keeping them out of the way.
The people who really know what he's done right now and um,
she was able to describe what he had previously doodled on the notepad that he
was now taking notes on her resuscitation on.
Now,
Reverend Amara completely rejects this,
right?
He hears this and he thinks I'm going to prove you wrong because this doesn't
fit his dogma.
This is not what's supposed to happen when somebody dies.
Right?
So he goes and he finds the med student and he looks at the page of doodles or
the page of notes and it has some doodles and the doodles match with what she
described.
He asked the student if he never interfaced with this patient and all,
they hadn't ain't asked the patient if they ever interface with students.
She hadn't.
You know,
what we're left with now is we can say that Reverend Mwalimu Mara is lying.
And I will never fucking say that because he wasn't right.
Um,
or we have a genuine mystery here and that's where I land.
There's a genuine mystery here.
So th can one read about this?
Is there obviously
my book,
this is completely in your book.
The story is it was recorded anywhere else.
Um,
you know,
intriguingly,
um,
Kubler Ross herself wrote about it.
Not,
I don't think it is great a detail as I ended up doing it through a Mara,
you know,
because she had,
so what happens is they have this event happened there really shaken by it and
um,
but they also are noticing that the patients who are reporting these experiences
are changing.
They are no longer afraid to die.
I mean,
you've got to imagine the anxiety that you would confront a terminal diagnosis
with these people.
Start losing that anxiety and start wanting to talk to her about,
you know,
what,
I want to clean up my relationships before I go.
They start talking to live in hard and the time they have left rather than
trembling at the fact that they're going to pass on.
It's,
it's a huge dramatic effect.
And that's when they decided to start taking notes.
Like this whole idea that the near death experiences merely wishful thinking is
bullshit,
you know,
and it's at least bullshitting in her experience at a Mara,
his experience of it,
they rejected it till they really couldn't reject it anymore because here they
are researching what happens when you're terminally ill.
And one of the things that was coming up,
uh,
in dozens of cases where people who were losing their fear because of this
event,
and that's how they ended up justifying doing any research on it at all.
So when she wrote her book,
she had a lot of different stories to tell.
I don't think she hit that story as hard as she should have.
Um,
the,
the near death experience being created or being facilitated maybe is a better
word by,
um,
by a psychedelic experience by the brain producing chemicals is,
it's,
it doesn't mean that there isn't something still going on.
It might mean that that's a chemical gateway to whatever's going on and that's
how the brain can release is this stuff and it interfaces with whatever the fuck
it does.
When you have these trips,
there's a researcher,
are you familiar with them?
I remember their last is a Carhart Harris.
No.
Um,
he did a study on,
um,
well mushrooms,
the active ingredient in mushrooms,
um,
with uh,
uh,
psilocybin and he,
um,
he found that it seemed to suppress a brain activity.
The brain actually seemed less active,
particularly the parts of the brain responsible for,
uh,
making connections and relaying information from one spot to another.
Yeah.
What he thought was really interesting about that,
and I would tend to agree with them,
is it,
you would think at moments of heightened experience and heightened perception
that we would see an excitement in the brain,
right.
Um,
greater activity.
Well here he was seeing a diminished activity,
less activity and it calls,
he called me back anyway to the idea that a lot of what the brain does is filter
our experience.
A lot of our processing is unconscious information.
We're picking up from the environment all the time.
That doesn't rise into our awareness,
our brains making the decision for us as to whether or not we need to be,
you know,
worried about that little noise behind us for the creaking,
the chair's making or whatever.
You know,
we don't even register it necessarily consciously.
And so the question becomes when you take this chemical,
which I may or may not be interested in taking myself,
I think we might be interested in it.
I think,
I think I might be,
when you take this chemical,
are you actually stopping the brain from filtering so much information?
Are you actually accessing more of the raw data that's out there?
Yeah,
that's a,
that's an interesting question.
The um,
the,
the thing about the mushroom experience is that the mushroom experience actually
mirrors Norman,
huge,
normal human near neurochemistry.
Part of,
uh,
what makes up a mushroom is an,
and dimethyltryptamine you mean the same stuff that you bring produces or your
lungs and your liver.
They know that the human body produces it and it's been thought that the pineal
gland,
a lot of people get very angry if you're not at the very specific about this
cause they,
it's just anecdotal evidence that the pineal gland,
which is the third eye of eastern mysticism,
producers this whatever produces it,
whatever they find one day,
ultimately they believe it's the pineal gland,
but you got to cut people's brains open within like a certain amount of time
while they're dead and then extract it to see if it's like,
yeah,
it would have been intense I think to find,
they're trying to find better ways to,
uh,
to measure.
But the most important thing is it's unquestionably produced in the body.
So the body is unquestionably producing this incredibly potent human neuro
transmitter,
which is part of the ingredients of mushrooms.
Like psilocybin mushroom is something like four Fox oarlock say n and
dimethyltryptamine.
And I know I,
I fucked up the first part the way you say it,
but it's,
it's and,
and dimethyl trip team with something tagged on.
And my point is that people that take mushrooms have the exact same sort of
feeling when it comes to that without the near death sort of um,
connotation to it that they will die,
but they have the feeling like they have to clean up relationships.
They have the feeling like they want to live like right now with joy and
happiness.
It's a very religious experience for a lot of people and a lot of scholars
actually believe it's the origin of religious experience and you know about the
death anxiety research going on there right now too,
right?
Yes.
Yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
Fantastic stuff.
If I do a fringe ology to which I intend to,
I intend to look pretty deeply into deeply like as in you're going to take them.
Yeah.
You're going to have to look.
I do emersion journalism.
I mean I debated like,
am I going to be coy or not?
But like I do emersion journalism,
that's what I do.
I get into what I'm reporting on as much as I can.
I think I'm a psychedelic experiences are very,
very helpful.
They can certainly send you off a path and to the nutty land,
but I think they're very helpful and they're probably part of what's made us
humans in the first place.
I mean,
every single religion has some sort of substance that they,
you know,
they talk about whether it's monetary,
whether it's,
you know,
Soma,
there's,
there's like so many of them throughout which are clearly some sort of
psychedelic entheogenic they would take and ritual form and help them connect to
God.
It might have aided evolution in some way.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah.
The Terence Mckenna stoned ape theory is a fascinating,
fascinating idea and it's,
you know,
it's really one of those who the fuck knows things.
It's tough to go back and try to figure out what the hell happened.
That turned us from,
you know,
some sort of monkey type creature in ape of a lower age to however it became a
human Ming.
I just think,
I think in general we need to be willing to say who the fuck knows more often.
Well if you do mushrooms,
it should say who the fuck knows all day.
Cause if you do it you're just going to go,
I didn't,
how could I have known that that's there.
How did you know?
And that DMT is mushrooms times a million plus aliens.
So it's impossible to even wrap a word around it and all those things can uh,
they can change you just like a religious experience could change you.
They can also freak you the fuck out and make you think you're haunted.
Like afterward we can,
you can lose,
you could blow a fuse.
It's a lot of possible for a lot of people just do too much.
It's all about the situation or yourself and find,
do you find that,
I mean I would take it with so much excitement at this point,
like just so much like you would,
let's do it,
but you're not crazy.
You're a successful author.
He seemed like a nice guy.
If you're a naughty person and ingest that shit,
if you're barely hanging on to sanity,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't recommend it.
What was dis what,
um,
what was the most shocking find for you in the writing of this book?
What,
what,
what's the one thing that set you back and really made you go,
wow,
I might've started with the telepathy,
but the other thing was meaning,
um,
Ricky soils in Stephenville,
Texas.
He was a,
uh,
one of the witnesses to what became known and Ufo circles is a,
the Stevenville lights this January 8th,
I think 2008,
um,
citing and a soils,
eh,
so on January 8th,
dozens of people I like to say they had the misfortune of looking out because,
um,
they face a lot of heat after they reported what they saw.
Um,
but it was some kind of,
um,
series of lights in the sky that moved in,
such with such a unity that it seemed to be one craft would have been very,
very big.
Um,
at what point it was actually trailed by,
have sixteens that couldn't catch up to it.
And,
um,
these were the sorts of reports you're getting at as Steven belt at the time.
And Ricky came forward to the newspaper and said that he had seen something many
weeks before.
Uh,
I think it was shortly after Thanksgiving and it was a solo daytime siding and
it was the wildest story of all the stories and ever for told me.
Right.
And in relation to the book,
this was probably the wildest and part of that had to do with the,
with Ricky himself.
He didn't want to tell me the story.
I had to go through an intermediary who talked him into ultimately speaking to
me.
As far as I'm aware,
he has not done another interview since,
and we're now looking at three and a half years since I spoke to him.
He made not a dime on this,
you know,
if anything,
he just faced a lot of ridicule,
uh,
locally in Stephenville first.
So,
except of course from the people who'd seen it or had a loved one see it.
And um,
so he has the siding,
he's out hunting.
And this is one of the things that people use to sort of subtly undermine him.
I,
you know,
in the same way that Monica Lewinsky was sort of framed for all of America by
the fact that the dress that ended up with a semen stain came from the gap,
right?
So we now we know where she shops.
Like she's this low rent little girl.
All right?
That's how people did her end.
Um,
with,
with Ricky,
one of the things people like to report sort of demean him is that we call him a
deer hunter,
right?
He's a father.
He's a machinist.
He's had his job for 15,
20 years.
You mean he's a lot more than the deer hunter,
but he was out hunting deer when this happened.
Why did they think that that's somehow or another get located him as a hick?
You know what I mean?
He's in Stephenville,
Texas,
which is literally a cow town.
You were talking before about the cowboy with kerosene games.
These are cowboys.
These are people who are raising cattle,
right?
And,
um,
the cliche of,
of Ufo sightings is that it's,
it's quoted six.
See them,
right?
Uh,
one of the cliches.
But anyway,
um,
Ricky's out deer hunting and he trips over a branch and he doesn't fall down,
but he has to know sort of steady himself and he glances up and he notices
overhead.
Now something he ended up saying it was 300 feet over his head.
He gauged this by the fact that there's a water tower in the community that is
300 feet high and it seemed about the same height.
He cannot see an edge to whatever it is that's floating above him.
And it's not making any sound,
but it is hanging over the trees.
And in it there are this series of sort of inverted cones,
which he intuitively suspected must be part of the propulsion propulsion system.
So the narrow part is up further into the craft and then it widens as it
telescopes down.
Right?
And so there's these series of inverted cones and his first instinct,
and I think people use this to sort of position him to his first instinct was to
put his gun on it,
but put his sight on it,
right?
Just instinct.
What the fuck is that?
I've got,
you know,
he was pointing the gun at it and then quickly within a second or two,
realize,
you know,
I'm not going to shoot it,
this thing,
whatever it is,
I'm not going to shoot at it.
And so he,
he lowers his gun and in room telling me about this,
that he just told himself,
calm down.
Remember as much of this as you can.
Just look at it,
take it in.
And then whom,
uh,
I forget exactly how long he was looking at it,
but for a little while and it just shot off and it went so fast.
He said,
there's no word for this kind of speed.
There's no word that can describe this kind of speed.
It went from being blocking my entire field division because it was so big to
just shooting up into the air.
Um,
like,
like a lightning flash was so convincing to you about his story.
Well,
here's what was here was the convincing part.
I mean,
I'm used to sitting across from people and having me,
you know,
and having them tell me all kinds of information.
Um,
and I have to look at various tells and just sort of see how I feel about them.
Right.
Are they telling the truth?
Ricky just seemed utterly,
completely truthful.
He wasn't getting nothing from this,
that the,
you know,
obviously the skeptics point of view,
the cynics can come in and go,
what if he was crazy?
What if he's a good liar?
You're basing your belief off.
This is the most shocking thing.
An anecdotal story from a good liar.
Well like I said,
I want to start with the telepathy actually.
Cause I could look at that research myself in judge it.
But,
but you know,
he freaked you out.
He freaked me out in this sense because here's the thing,
Joe,
to me,
he is demonstrably not crazy.
He's fully functional.
He's still got the same job.
He's still got the same friends you go drinking with them.
I actually met him for lunch when we could have a beer or two and just hammered.
You don't know the dude and unless you've seen him hammered,
you don't know my wife and kids and he's got a whole life.
I was running that line.
The fucking Ted Haggard,
the guy,
the church Guy Smokes meth.
And so interesting to me about a story like that.
What we're left with is the idea that what we have to say as well,
he must,
he must be crazy.
Something must be off right with him.
What was it people saw several weeks later?
I mean,
one of the things that interests me about that story is they were very near a
military base and in,
and again,
this is all in the book,
but one of the things that happened to him after he reported his signing as he
started getting calls from somebody who was identifying themselves as a member
of the military,
who is advising him not to about this anymore and saying
they wanted to meet with him.
That was me.
I was calling.
I'll just try and get,
uh,
get them to come on the podcast.
It was Robert Deniro.
I was rehearsing my role and you're all,
uh,
yeah.
You know,
I wish he just pulled out his phone and took a picture of that would have been
half one mother fucker out there.
To your hunting without a phone.
A funny part about it,
this one of the witnesses,
a constable,
um,
that's what they call their sheriff there.
Um,
Leroy Gaten,
right?
Had a camera nearby when he had his siding,
it was in his car and he was 10 feet from his car and he had to make a choice.
Do I take my eyes off this unbelievable sight and miss it or do I go grab the
camera?
And his choice was to stay rooted to the spot.
And,
and I think that that's another thing where I just sort of cautioned the
skeptics.
I mean at the end of the day,
you know,
what they saw in Stephenville is an unidentified flying object.
And we ended up with believers who hear that and say,
we don't know what it was.
Therefore aliens.
And that's ridiculous.
Right?
But we also ended with skeptics.
You want to explain it away as flares.
And you know what that's equally fricking ridiculous
was you said fricken and then I'm like,
listen man,
we're grown adults here.
Fucking thank you.
[inaudible] you heard Brian,
and this is the first podcast I've been on where like swearing is just like
cool.
Really?
Yeah.
The other one,
it's always where maybe Matt doesn't disinfect and I didn't realize it,
but the other ones,
they're clean.
You know?
If you listened to them then they're clean.
We fucking square our asses off.
You know what I mean?
Like I swear all the fucking time.
Well,
but I'm used to in this setting.
That'd be cool if,
do you have photos where Bigfoot's instead of ships,
they're just flying.
They clients.
Well remember
I used to have a joke that if there was going to be Ufo is why would they come
in the form of a disc if they can get here from another planet,
they could make themselves look a cloud like that's something we've already
figured out how to do with like those Japanese jackets that show you an image of
what's behind you on you.
Have you ever seen that there are people new technology,
there are people actually who do claim they come here.
It's clouds.
I'm sure.
Oh well I have a problem.
I have a friend who's got a problem rather,
uh,
I didn't know he was nutty and uh,
we were in the Improv one night and he's like,
check these out.
And he started showing me pictures of clouds and I go,
oh,
it's beautiful.
Like,
I don't know,
he's on his iPhone showing me pictures of clouds cause you know,
they're out there all the time.
They're always,
they're following me all the time.
I go,
what exactly are you saying?
He goes,
these are flying saucers.
these are from another planet because they're out there,
they're falling all the time.
And I realized,
Oh,
I thought this dude was just nutty.
I thought he was like a nutty comic and no,
no,
he's got something,
somethings,
some,
a is connected to B and B is hanging down here loose and sparking and are
smoking aliens.
Joe,
I totally met people who are so invested in this idea that they're being,
um,
uh,
they've been abducted or if they're,
you know,
visited by aliens.
I met a guy who claimed to have an implant in his leg and he didn't want it
removed because the times that he's thought about it,
he began to feel nauseous and this made him think that the,
you know,
the aliens don't want him to have it removed and just this whole trip into lots
of New Zealand because there's a lump under his skin.
Right and right.
And that could be glass that's been working its way up.
You know what I mean,
for decades or who knows what the fuck it is.
Right.
It like some kind of growth and um,
so I definitely
met people like that.
I mean I think that's one of the things that impressed me so much about Ricky.
Right.
As he's,
he didn't want to give the interview.
He hasn't done another interview since there's no profit in it for him.
If anything,
he just faced embarrassment over this.
Well,
I wish a story was enough for me,
but I still have an open mind.
I still have an open mind because even though I know that most people are full
of shit,
I still know that we can send a rover to Mars if we can send a rover to Mars,
if there was a,
some sort of a civilization out there that wasn't just a thousand years advance,
but millions of years advance and perhaps they live in a solar system that
doesn't get pelted by asteroids every couple of hundred million years and wipes
out everything on the planet.
Yeah,
I mean who knows what level of achievement they've had technologically.
It's absolutely possible.
One of the guys I write about in the book,
a Doctor Edgar Mitchell
now's astronauts,
his family in a hundred years,
if you just sort of trace this blood bloodline,
they moved west in a horse drawn wagons and then he was on the moon a hundred
years later that that's technology advancing from a horse drawn wagons to the
moon.
And um,
well he's a big UFO believer.
He's actually said that he saw some things when he was in space.
No,
he,
well,
no,
not in relation to Ufo is at all.
He said he maintains that he saw nothing in terms of Ufo.
She had a huge,
he does believe in Ufos.
He says he's talked to members of the military since he was shorter than that.
There that Ufo is,
should be identified as alien craft and some cases right,
that,
that we are being visited.
But what happened in space was completely different.
It was,
it was a religious or a spiritual,
I'll say spiritual experience.
He had,
uh,
an epiphany where he had the same sort of experience that people report in
meditation when they hit this kind of bliss or sometimes on psychedelics where
it was like everything dropped away and he felt himself being at one with the
entire universe,
that everything was connected,
everything was one thing.
And it was a feeling that he had all the way back.
Uh,
you know,
over a period of a day or two,
he would have this experience every,
every,
uh,
um,
you know,
uh,
regularly feel this sense of wonder and the sense that he was,
you know,
he rejected his parents' religion.
He'd gone down the science path and it completely altered his perspective.
And made him think that there's some way of uniting spirituality and science.
He,
he landed and started the institute of noetic sciences to try and find some sort
of connection between spiritual experiences and um,
you know,
in some scientific basis for them.
Yeah.
He,
what,
what Edgar Mitchell's deal is with a sock with um,
uh,
aliens rather is that he has talked to quite a few people that were high
knowing,
uh,
people,
in the Joint Chiefs of staff intelligence committees type characters.
And they told him there was a Ufo crash,
that there was an alien space craft at Roswell and that um,
uh,
it's pretty fascinating stuff listening to him,
a reading rather this thing.
And he had something to do with the disclosure project with Dr. Steven Greer who
one day we would like to get him on this podcast as well cause he's another very
highly credible person.
And,
uh,
his disclosure project included a lot of very high level of former military
people who talked about their experiences and they think that it's high time
that we start being honest about what these people in high levels of the
military have already experienced.
You know about it.
And the fact that there's,
there's probably a high level of probability that a,
we are consistently visited by some freaky dudes from another part of the world
or another dimension or,
but they're just can slip in and out like that and we don't really know what the
fuck is going on.
Well,
that whole,
the one of the arguments should get from this section
thanks is that our planet is,
you know,
one among so many.
How would they find us?
What kind of propulsion system could possibly carry them here?
Um,
and they're basing this all off on what we know right now with our technology
and our understanding at the moment.
But as you said,
like if you've got a civilization that's been around for thousands or
potentially even a million or more years,
who knows what they could have.
That's,
it's a,
it's a silly sort of argument to me because it's based so much on this idea that
this is advanced is where ever going to get to the fact that 200 years ago when
you wanted a picture of something,
you want to draw it.
If you want to get around you gotta to ride a fucking animal.
It was the dumbest time ever.
You had to draw 200 years ago,
you had a draw things to let anybody else know what they look like.
We're still doing that in the courtroom.
What the fuck?
But it's really incredible if you stop and look at that,
that we've gone from that in 200 years to making high res videos with your cell
phones,
watching streaming videos,
playing video games on a tablet.
I mean,
just that leap.
No one saw coming before photographs.
No one would have imagined that this tiny blip in human time of 200 years could
have that much innovation.
Sure.
You know,
the only time I really get sad about dying now is what I think
about the shit I'm going to miss.
You know,
the advances that are coming up,
like I'd like to,
I'd like to experience that slight privacy.
You're going to miss privacy.
That shit's out the window son.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's the first thing that's going to go I think.
I think there really would be no privacy and about a hundred years,
100 years.
I think everyone's going to know it probably won't even,
that belong to would take that long strangely disinterested in privacy now too.
I mean,
I can't get over how rob people are in terms of the information they share about
themselves on Facebook and you lose a phone,
you lose your diary.
You know,
like you could get all your family photos or people's phone numbers,
your past texts,
you or emails.
I mean,
that person's,
that's gained a huge part of your privacy by just losing a phone.
Yeah.
If you don't have a fucking password on a stupid,
most people don't that that's true.
Um,
if you're like a person who wants to like peer into someone's text messages,
but I think,
um,
that that access ultimately will one day just be universal.
Everybody will be able to find out anything that anybody's doing.
People are walking around with apps now that will automatically tweet where they
are.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Geotagging it's great if you want to stalk them though.
It's really stalking somebody in the Geo tag and all over the fucking place.
You can narrow it down pretty good.
Yeah.
People are weird man.
It's the,
the,
the whole connection hasn't been figured out yet.
This whole connection between every human being on the planet through the
Internet really hasn't really been,
I figured out,
I thought you were going mystical with that for a second.
This whole connection does that as well.
Trying to figure that out too.
Right.
Well I think that as we said,
I don't think that the human body in this form is done.
You know,
I think it's continuing to change and continuing to,
a lot of people don't like to use the word evolve cause you know real evolution
involves mutation and adaptation to your natural surroundings and it might not
just be that.
It might be,
there might be a lot of things going on,
a constant move towards improvement or around losing senses.
Are you familiar with you that the overview overview effect?
You should play with that?
No.
What's that?
So that's what Edgar Mitchell experienced,
right.
And he,
he's very adamant about this and it seems to be true.
Um,
and NASA,
uh,
allows that,
this happens now that that the people they send up into space,
um,
are changed by the experience of seeing the earth from space.
It has a profound impact on them.
They feel it.
And for Mitchell it becomes a spiritual experience,
uh,
for other people at it got the more involved in politics.
They recognize the how arbitrary the lines between countries are in the lines.
We draw a culturally,
um,
but they,
they see just how fragile our little planet is hanging out there in space and it
changes them.
And I think most of us would agree it's changing them,
uh,
for the better.
They end up coming home and doing,
um,
sort of more altruistic things with their lives.
And now we're going to have civilians being set up into space.
Um,
mostly wealthy civilians initially because how much that rides going to cost
right from
Bigelow aerospace or virgin every time I have $100,000,
$150,000.
I came up with the price at this point,
but I had researched it and we're going to have general civilians getting
shopping Sean up in his face and having an experience of seeing the earth from
there.
And it's going to begin to slowly change the culture,
I would think.
Because if you look at how dramatically it changed the lives of all the people
who've gone into space,
it's going to change these people too.
To some degree.
You're Mitchell's take on it is very trippy,
man.
It's very trippy when the,
when he was,
uh,
in the,
the spacecraft coming home,
this is his word.
Suddenly I realized that the molecules and my body were created in an ancient
generation of stars.
And suddenly that became personal and visceral,
not intellectual.
And I had never had this experience.
It was accompanied by bliss and ecstasy I had never experienced.
So he's calling,
it's calling it Samadhi.
I quote that in the classic actually,
cause it's a,
it's a heavy quote and um,
yeah,
he felt literally it was like his flesh dropped away.
His bones went away.
Have you ever been to,
um,
the Keck observatory?
No.
The Keck Observer,
Tori and Hawaii on the big island.
And uh,
there's,
uh,
one island and Hawaii that's so big.
You get so high and the big island that you go through the clouds,
right?
Hello?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well he loads just the city.
Then the Keck observatory is,
um,
it's,
I think it's on them.
It's not on the Mauna Loa volcano,
which whatever one it is the biggest one.
And it's that there's a,
there's a,
like a visitor station that's down at like 9,000 plus feet,
and then you go even higher.
They have the,
uh,
the telescopes there,
but you get out of the car and you're through the clouds and the way the big
island is set up,
they have these diffused lights so that they don't create light pollution
because of the observatory.
So the fucking milky way was so stunning.
It was so that to this day,
all I think about when we talk about going on vacation,
it's like we've got to get back to that Keck.
I got to see that again.
I just got to look up and see that again because it really did feel like you
were flying through an impossibly filled galaxy.
Whereas like usually you see like a few stars like here and there,
you know,
up there with that high,
high altitude and the,
the really zero light pollution and clear skies.
It was amazing.
I studied
dreaming in Hilo and the Big island.
One of the things I would do is,
uh,
at night before I go to bed,
I would lay out in the grass and just stare straight up because I'm in Philly.
Right?
Yeah.
You just don't get stars like that in Philadelphia because there were,
there were really no lights.
We were at this little retreat type center and,
and um,
it just,
it set the scene real well to go upstairs and try and have a lucid dream.
Yeah.
I would imagine it would set the scene for freaking yourself out.
So never gotten over that image.
Just see.
I mean,
there was only a couple hours of just staring at the sky,
but I couldn't believe how beautiful it looked.
I got to imagine it's probably a hundred times more beautiful when you're in
space orbiting the earth.
You know?
If you've seen those photos that they take when they're up there,
it's like,
oh my God,
like you're orbiting the fucking plant.
You're above it.
Looking down at just the circular nature of it all and like,
oh,
something to consider there too.
That's really interesting.
That
fascinating about the overview effect.
You can show people these pictures and they don't have the reaction that you
have from from being there.
Oh,
of course.
Yeah.
Images never capture the,
the real emotion of the moment.
You know,
the connection of the moment when you're actually in space.
It's got to be a real mind fuck.
It's like the,
the connection of camping as opposed to actual camping,
you know,
multiple wild fuck.
Are you going camping?
What are you going to sleep in the woods?
Stupid in the,
don't you have a house?
But once you do it and he'd go,
oh,
I get it.
This is crazy.
Like you're out here in nature.
I use a totally different feeling.
My,
my wife is going to be really glad that you're saying this because she wants me
desperately to go tent camping with her.
And I,
and I,
my feeling always,
you know,
let's just get a cabin,
honey.
We'll walk out in the woods at night.
You know what?
You want to go deer hunting.
Then you can camp out and make,
make,
uh,
some sort of a agreement.
We're back to the new year all at one shot.
Yeah.
Deniros ridiculous.
You've got to shoot him twice.
Sometimes they go down,
got to execute them.
Trust me.
Um,
yeah,
the,
the thing that's weird about camping is that when you're away from like
electricity and House and all that shit for a long enough,
you kind of like get this like real humble feeling like,
oh,
okay,
I get this.
Like we're just like another animal who just figured out some way to separate
ourself so we can do our work and we separate ourselves.
At our houses and in there we create these computers and electrically hooked
things together and all along as we separate ourselves from the nature,
because we're out there in the nature,
you might get eaten and you got to go find some food.
Yes,
shit can go wrong.
Yeah,
he put that pure l and your hands bitch and go back to work.
So you get your house and you're,
you know,
you hide from the connection with the outside world,
but when you camping and it's an escapable,
it's a weird feeling when you're out there for,
I did a recently five days with no cell phones,
no electricity,
no,
no heat,
no nothing.
And we had to start a fire.
If you want to stay warm,
and it was in Montana,
it was freezing cold.
But doing that you,
you really have a different sort of feeling and appreciation for what nature
actually is.
Nature's,
it's like we're disconnected from one of the fucking coolest things ever for a
human to experience.
We're completely disconnected from it.
There's a lot of people who lived their whole lives in cities and in suburbs and
they drive back and forth from work and they never out there in the woods.
I'll never forget a guy and a college if who went on this big long tirade and I
thought he might be mentally unbalanced because one of this big one fucking
tirade that how like I'm still so,
it wasn't philosophy class actually too.
I'm so sick.
People talking about the outdoors and how the outdoors just so great outdoors
suck.
You get bit by bugs.
You don't,
you don't what the fuck's going on?
You know what's gonna Happen Next?
You get rained on your wet.
What the fuck's great about that?
That was his take on the entire outdoors.
Well that spent his entire life like in a,
in,
in a mall.
I guess
that's the classic cynics approach,
isn't it?
Isn't it the classic cynics approach you like for the hipster?
Like if fucking everything sucks,
man,
why the fuck that's,
that is our are spoiled societies creation.
I have to tell you,
that's one of the biggest pushbacks I've gotten on the firm from that sort of
crowd on the book.
Then like the whole idea that I was going to go study lucid dreaming and learn
to meditate and and do all these things,
you know like why?
Right?
Like why would you put that kind of effort?
It was sort of just sort of like,
I don't know.
I guess they feel so great in their skinny jeans that the idea of doing
something to improve themselves further or you know what I mean?
Just seems like an admission of defeat.
Right?
Cause there's supposed to be so cool right there.
Yeah.
Well that is,
that is the thing.
Like why bother?
What are you doing out there with your head?
Would you stupid,
psychic bullshit.
It's not real.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Look at my genes.
What if they have skinny jeans and they're sag and have you seen that?
That makes you fucking violent,
doesn't it?
Oh,
it makes me want to throttle those little,
fuck.
You're so skinny.
You're skinny jeans,
your sagging,
there's a problem.
They put the CIGGIES,
they put them down low on purpose.
Like that's a move to have your skinny jeans kind of saggy male Cleve hello.
Yeah,
a little bit.
It's like you just let them know silly fucks.
Yeah.
That detachment thing,
it's really disturbing.
It's such a weak,
fake sort of a complacency.
It's just,
they're just terrified.
So they're just pretending to don't give a fuck about anything.
I don't care about anything.
Well,
there's a lot.
I think there's a lot of that terrified I think is the operative word.
I think it ain't,
and I,
and it was,
it's funny,
I am not to be able to quote exactly what is Martin Sheen who,
who,
uh,
in that guy went through the shit.
Right.
I mean,
at the whole apocalypse now filming in that whole story,
the whole RQ went through.
Um,
the basic fact we need to understand about life is that it's terrifying.
Yeah.
You know,
we are,
we are cauldrons of anxiety.
We have a part of our brain,
the Bigelow that whenever we're confronted by ambiguous information is
immediately going to be like,
check for danger.
Check for danger.
Yeah.
And it,
it sort of prohibits us from,
you know,
learning,
growing,
trying to find out a new things.
If we give into that,
I mean we are,
we're animals and we have instincts to stay alive and those instincts are going
to get fired up left and right all around,
especially if you're in a city and is constantly surrounded by people packed
into a place.
And I think your senses,
the,
the adapt your feelings and intuition sort of adapt to that environment.
That's,
it really made sense when you
were talking about people or hunters and people who were inner city people.
Because when you're in involved in a real,
you have to,
in an inner city situation that's very primal
and you have to learn to slow it down.
You have to learn that because there's so much happening around you in a way.
You kind of have to learn to slow it down to,
to see what,
what's important here,
what do I really need that my eye on?
Because there's so many different things that could distract you potentially
fuck you up.
Yeah.
What,
um,
what other information or what other pieces of evidence about aliens have ever
led you to believe conclusively one way or another that,
that there is something else.
I don't,
you know,
that's another one where I conclusively believe that Ufo is or unidentified
flying objects.
Right?
Right.
And there are times when we just need to kind of,
they're people who want to honor sort of like materials science and their people
want to honor some sort of dogmatic religion.
I want to honor that like gap in our knowledge to some degree.
Right.
And,
and just acknowledge that it's there and,
and that's what we're working through.
You know,
we,
we need more information,
more data,
not less.
And,
um,
so,
so the UFO question,
I mean,
have we been visited?
I'm not entirely sure.
I mean,
even at Stevenville signing,
I didn't get a chance to get into this,
but that Steven,
it'll siding.
There's a military base nearby.
This guy claimed that he was harassed for a weeks afterward by a member of the
military.
There's this story in the book about somebody showing up on his property and in
the middle of the night making his dog's bark and just staring into his door and
clearly wearing chemo gear.
And this was during the same period when he was getting these threatening phone
calls from,
from a guy who was identifying himself as a member of the military.
So is it possible that,
um,
you know,
people are encountering at times,
some sort of advanced military technology?
It's to me,
no coincidence that people started reporting triangle shaped Ufo shortly before
the stealth bomber was right,
ultimately revealed.
Yeah.
So sometimes that's the explanation.
Uh,
but you know,
for me it simply the vastness of the universe,
it's age.
Um,
the idea that we,
we would,
the chances that we're the only,
only,
uh,
planet that's evolved life like this seem so small that surely somebody out
there has developed a kind of technology would take to find us and get here.
I mean,
that's,
that's the kind of thinking that that really opens me up.
You don't mean to,
to the possibility
the numbers are just too crazy.
100 billion stars with who knows how many planets more than you know,
more than one per per star.
You know,
some of our binary systems,
we don't know
that's just this galaxy but commune.
It's a joke.
Yeah,
and there are enough of these cases where you know like Greer's people,
the military people would come forward and say that something happened or
whatever.
Yeah.
And enough of these people are are credible and in and left and then on
identified
category that you start to think,
wow,
you know,
maybe it
some point.
Some of these,
so many people are full of shit and so many people have told lies that if you
have any thoughts in your head that you're going to be able to tell people that
you believe in Ufos and not have them ridicule you.
That was good fucking luck.
Good luck like being a serious person and being taken seriously.
If we had Obama,
if Obama was on TV and he started talking about Ufos and his experience and what
he believes they are and that he believes that we're being visited by
intelligent beings from some other dimension,
he immediately is going to get,
people will haul him off to crazy town.
Look what happened to Dennis Kucinich.
Yeah.
When he told that story,
uh,
or you know,
sort of was dragged through that story during the debate.
What was his story again?
Was it,
what year did he run?
He ran in a recently 2004.
Did he?
Yeah,
he,
um,
he had written,
or I'm sorry,
Shirley McClain,
who I guess is like a great aunt or something to him.
God mother.
It came from the relationship.
She had written a red flag.
Well,
she'd been in the family.
She rent a book in which he claimed that he had seen a Ufo and Tim Russert asked
him about it during a debate.
And people immediately,
and this is again,
the language was Ufo,
not alien craft,
but Ufo.
The people immediately burst into laughter and you can hear it,
you know,
on the video.
I write about this in the book too.
Um,
when people immediately start laughing and he starts saying,
well look,
you know,
Ufo,
it's unidentified and people are still sort of,
now you hear people kind of gasping because instead of rejecting it out of hand,
he's,
he's sort,
sorta trying to stick up for this.
Those are the [inaudible]
press people that you root for to get killed by the aliens that were in that
Mars attacks movie.
They'd come down with the Reagans.
Yeah.
Alright.
Just start blasting them and killing them.
How and dignified to be killed by cartoonish aliens.
The perfect end.
So way to go and I'm a perfect 10.
That movie.
It was fucking awesome.
That was it.
That's one of my favorite all time alien movies,
Mars attacks.
It's a much more likely how it's going to go down to this people that these
knuckleheads and think that the aliens are going to come save us.
We're not saving chimps.
You know,
we're not going into the fucking the Congo and given them laptops,
you know,
then,
right.
They're not,
they're not going to say us.
Why would they save us the fuck out of here?
And Mitchell,
he knows,
he knows something.
He doesn't want to tell us this guy.
Um,
your,
your guy,
did he have drawings?
Did he,
did he ever swirls?
Yeah.
Did he like try to,
well,
you know what's funny,
he,
he tried to take pictures later of other,
you know,
another siding.
He said he had using a cell phone camera and he had another siding.
Yeah.
And this is Joan.
Same town,
but at night.
And this is 2008 and it's a Sheaf of can picture what it Lou Clark.
And actually it's a little bit of video actually too.
I think you captured video.
Um,
he stopped showing it because,
uh,
he realized it was embarrassingly bad comments.
Rude.
Well,
here's the,
here's the issue.
Like how good a picture is a cell phone camera gonna take of a light in the sky.
Very fucking.
Let me think about how good of a picture as a take of a moon,
you know,
looks like a tiny little dot.
It's impossible to see what an iPhone.
So that's another one of this sort of like a misleading,
you know,
the red herrings thrown out there by the skeptics,
but we're all walking around with camera phones now.
Yes,
it has.
Camera phones suck for the most part.
They'd have a very hard time taking a picture of a light in a dark field,
right?
Like dude,
shucks guy,
big foot.
I did not know big foot research.
I decided I was not going there.
Maybe in book two,
after you take mushrooms,
then you commune with bigfoot.
Yeah.
Big,
big foot to me was not on the radar.
Quiche is the thing.
I was drawn to the idea that we're,
the whole title of phrenology came from this.
These are subjects we pushed to the fringe.
But if you look at like near death experiences,
ghosts,
Ufos,
uh,
they speak to the big existential questions,
right?
That,
that really plague us.
The ones we don't have answers to.
What happens when we die?
Are we alone in the universe?
You know,
what,
what's it mean to be human?
These sorts of questions.
Big Foot doesn't really,
doesn't really get into that,
into that field.
He's not in it,
you know,
he's,
he's not something that's gonna make me question.
Um,
uh,
you know,
the idea that there might be some undiscovered ape,
it does not affect what happens when I die or whether or not we're alone in the
universe.
Right.
He got here on a fucking space ship.
So you say this,
but my friend called me up the other day.
I swear to God,
someone actually had a conversation with me and both as to it.
They're on the phone.
He goes,
do you think that big food could be like an interdimensional being?
It comes up.
People do throw that out there,
but I didn't,
I decided to stay away and I said,
no,
I don't think that.
I don't think that at all.
Even after you said it,
I refuse to think it.
You Fuck?
Who was that?
I'm not telling you it was,
it wasn't me.
It wasn't,
yeah,
it was not Brian Redman.
Brian Redman could give a fuck about big foot or Ufos.
He is a silly boy,
but he's not a silly boy.
And when it comes to like ghosts and shit like that,
mom and my sister and my Stepdad all say that their house is haunted.
Really?
I've stayed at that house.
I've screamed,
like go started jerks and I,
that was the edited version.
But I like,
I tried everything to like see or hear this goes that they all swear fine.
Yeah.
Maybe their haunted and their minds and their fucking dreams are haunted.
That's right.
The life is haunted.
Maybe that,
maybe their life sucks a fat one.
So they manufacturer ghosts scare the shit out of them in the middle of the
night.
Yeah,
they gave me all the time too.
I went out with a ghost for about,
uh,
not dated,
but along with them for about nine months or a year.
That seems like a long test.
Part of the research for the book,
nine months for a year.
How often did you do it?
Gosh,
once,
once a month probably.
We went out and then when he had like a quote hot case,
I would go,
there was one case I went out on three,
four nights in a couple of week timespan um,
and look,
there were times when the people didn't want to think anything was going on in
their house and uh,
brought him in and hopefully to debunk it.
But there were a lot of times that people brought him in hoping that they had it
goes to excited about it,
showing pictures of dust motes in the air and saying,
look at these orbs.
What are the words kind of thing.
Please explain to me what the orbs are usually their dust modes,
right?
There's,
there's just dust and stuff floating in the,
uh,
in the air near the camera lens.
And so the light flashes off of that.
Uh,
Dustin creates this round image that's semi transparent and
talk to Eddie Bravo because Eddie Bravo believes you manifest them with positive
thinking.
Oh,
I'm,
you know,
it's fine.
Hold your hands out.
Like he's like got them gathered in his hands.
Here's what's going on there.
Here's a test.
Right?
Yeah.
Bravo getting,
get into a room as still as possible.
Take some snaps.
Right.
And,
and uh,
test it,
you know,
be really,
really still in that room.
See if the amount of orbs seems to decrease.
Uh,
the longer he stays there.
And I think what he'll find,
cause I mean,
I know some people who who did this is that they go the fuck away because you
stop stirring up the air that you've now been really still for a while and
you're,
and you're taking pictures because generally speaking,
I mean that's okay.
What about when you get them in outdoor shots,
bugs and got your bitch
bitch outdoor or a member,
those aliens that just happened to be the bugs,
you know.
Oh well that's a,
that was a video artifact from I'm filming.
Um,
those,
um,
those fucking cones,
you know,
those rods,
the Roswell rods,
you know,
that whole thing.
That's hilarious.
I bought that documentary.
I was like,
those things,
this is crazy.
I was like,
maybe there's some war in part of the world where there's a bug that just flies
really fast.
It looks really weird.
I didn't even think it was that crazy.
Right.
But then they,
they're thinking they're,
you know,
travelers from another planet.
That's why they're still always there.
Yeah.
But it turns out that it's just in monster quest broke this,
it took monster quest to debunk you a show.
It never gets it.
Never,
they never haven't debunk shit except the rods.
But the Rod,
the got your bitch.
It's just a video artifact of certain cameras that when they put like a super
high speed camera on it,
it didn't happen.
They got the exact same area of photographed.
They lit a fire and bugs would like fly around the fire.
And when the bugs a fly on the fire on one camera,
they would come out like these rods cause the camera couldn't compete with it or
couldn't rather pick up the image when it was moving too fast.
Too close to it.
It didn't know what it was.
Focusing on the front and the back,
you know,
digital imagery is kind of funky but at the high speed camera and they got it
loud and clear and it's like a third or it is stupid.
They this fucking asshole dedicated like decades of his life to selling these
DVDs and telling everybody that's fucking rods flying around the air.
Yeah.
I was trying to look for things that would help me answer the big questions if
only for myself.
I got of like,
you know,
I don't want to listen to some right wing dogmatic religious person.
Tell me how it is.
I got tired of listening to Richard Dawkins telling me that I'm just meat and I
just thought,
you know what?
If,
if,
if it's knowable,
if it's observable,
that there's more to me than that I should be able to find a way to experience
this directly for myself and learn about it directly for myself.
So I started looking into meditation and Lucid dreaming and trying to find some
way of experiencing myself in a sense of disconnected from the meat.
Right.
My problem with Dawkins is he doesn't seem happy.
I love,
it's not a great advertisement for it.
It's a terrible advertise.
He seems like a bitter old cont.
Like I love the idea that he's standing up for science and he's standing up
against religious ideology and brainwashing and he's,
but he's doing it in such an hour yet sort of aggressive way that it makes you
go,
like you're kind of a bad spokesperson for the thing.
But I'm sure from the scientific community,
like the encouragement is like so strong and profound and almost hero like that.
It sort of encourages him to be this aggressive force of reason.
I'm sure there's enough people like that that he gets the encouragement he
needs.
But um,
uh,
Peter Higgs,
the guy who first started us off looking for the Higgs Boson,
he recently even just came in and said to Dawkins is a fundamentalist.
Well you said he's embarrassing Dawkins is his behavior against the or about
religion?
It's embarrassing.
Yeah.
And he called him a fundamentalist.
He said he's an atheist fundamentalist.
And that's sort of the worst insult that you can level at an atheist because
they are so,
you know,
they were reacting to fundamentalism in their,
in their view.
But you know,
if you adopt a point of view,
did that degree with that passion.
If it walks like a fundamentalist and talks like a five minutes and quacks like
a fundamentalist,
that's what it is.
I guarantee you that if you could get Richard Dawkins to take place in at least
one mushroom trip,
if not several.
I think one to find out what the fuck it is and then reset and revisit,
go back in and sort of analyze what the fuck is happening.
I bet he will have a completely different opinion as to the possibilities you
ever follow.
The God helmet,
that's that thing that they put on you and you stimulated certain parts of your
brain,
the temporal lobe with electromagnetic energy.
It's religious experiences and on a lot of other kinds of experiences too.
I mean,
but,
but the thing is the atheist community,
that sort of fundamentalist materialist community came out and said,
this is an explanation for God and religious experience,
but people have all sorts of strange experiences when they put that helmet on.
But guess who didn't owe Richard fucking Dawkins and when they screened him
before he put it on because he,
he wanted to take part in this,
um,
when they screened him and put him through sort of the questionnaire they put
him through.
And I,
and,
and I have not seen it and so I'm not gonna go to describe this in great detail,
but person you related this much of it to me.
Um,
when they screened him,
he,
his temporal lobe was really,
really in active,
right.
It's,
it's,
it's
not,
it's not a normal,
a normally active sort of temporal lobe,
which is what they were trying to stimulate.
So when he didn't have an experience person GRE,
um,
dis sort of dismissed it as saying,
well,
you know,
this guy isn't built like the rest of us.
And it's,
and it's an intriguing thing to think that is,
is that part of the,
of what created his world view,
right?
Is Atheistic worldview.
And,
um,
is that the case or is it just,
he rejects religion so strong that an area of his brain responsible for religion
just gets shut down.
Totally.
That's a great point.
Cause that's,
that's the other possibility,
right?
It could be if that's the,
the,
the source of all life,
unrealistic hope in that area.
Not even unrealistic hope.
Right.
Maybe reality,
the,
the degree to which,
um,
you know,
we feel it,
if you pray or if you meditated,
do you feel like you're contacting something sort of outside yourself?
This is the part of the brain that processes that information.
We'll,
if you're never using that part of the brain,
if you're never stimulating it,
right,
um,
it will become less active.
That's neuroplasticity in action.
That's just how it
works.
That totally makes sense.
If you completely reject any idea of Wu whatsoever,
the woo part of your brand,
you know,
there's a big issue that I have with people that will say that an experience,
whether it's an experience like Edgar Mitchell had,
or whether it's a psychedelic experience,
the they'll say,
especially in terms of psychedelic experience,
I say that it's not real.
Like it's you,
you had an hallucination but the same effect.
It has the same effect rather on you as a real experience.
Like even if it's a hallucination,
let's let's,
let's defined a hallucination as you're seeing something that's not there.
Even if it's that from that you benefit greatly and you have a real thing is
going on in your imagination or wherever it is,
you really are receiving information.
You really are looking at yourself in the world in a totally different way.
It's actually happening.
So this event,
this experience,
whatever it is,
I mean we want to compartmentalize it because you're,
you're taking in some sort of a substance alien to the body that tricks the body
into having the state and achieving the state and having this experience,
but it's still an experience that you actually really have.
Can,
can we segue into lucid dreaming because I heard you mentioned that you were
sit in it and I really,
maybe the most gratifying thing that's happened to me in writing the book is
whenever I do a public appearance or a podcast with a big enough audience,
I end up getting notes from people afterwards that they had a lucid dream.
Either,
you know,
after the interview or after they went and then read the book or whatever it is.
And I love turning people on to it
because you a big,
do you,
do you do this on a regular basis?
I do it on a wrangler
basis before we had our,
my wife and I just had fraternal twin boys and I'm there almost six months old.
So sleep has been hard to come by at home,
but it's,
I'm so proud of this.
Right before,
before they came along,
I was having a lucid dream every two or three weeks without even trying.
I mean just spontaneously because I trained at it long enough,
hard enough that I was having them every two or three weeks,
um,
since they were born.
I actually recently,
cause they're starting to sleep a little bit now.
I actually had a couple just in the last couple of weeks and it's over three
weeks.
I had to.
And it's like,
oh great.
It's coming back online.
This function of Steve Volk is returning now that he's getting proper rest,
you know,
and um,
and it's,
it's pretty terrific.
And,
and one of the great things about it is that it changes your waking life as well
as your dreaming life.
I mean,
it honestly wouldn't be worth the effort if you were only doing it to experience
a change in your consciousness when you're dreaming.
So lucid dreaming for those that don't know is the act of being aware and you're
dreaming while you're dreaming and then choosing accordingly.
Right?
So think of it this way.
One great way of introducing people to the idea is that we're going to talk
about the fill tank at four more hours.
One of the ways of introducing people to lucid dreaming to understand what it
really is and,
and usually I'm asking this if like a crowded book reading or something,
but I'll ask you guys here,
have any of you ever woken yourself up from a nightmare?
Yes.
Yeah.
You were this close to having a lucid dreaming Gillette having a lucid dream
because you are aware you were dreaming while you're dreaming.
You're like,
Shit,
this is a nightmare,
right?
I'm going to wake myself up and you chose to wake yourself up.
But the fact is,
since whatever was chasing you or whatever was happening that made it qualify as
a nightmare,
had no external reality,
you could have just walked away from it and your dream,
you could have,
because the laws of physics don't apply,
flown away from it.
You could have gone up to it and said,
Yo,
what's up?
Why are you chasing me?
Completely control your room.
Well,
no,
you control you within your dream.
And for some people they find that they can begin to control other aspects of it
and make things happen.
I had one that was totally like I could stop time and we wind the tape and,
and started again.
I had a dream that I was in a cracks and,
and,
and I got lucid and I'm,
I'm actually already was really outing myself here.
I always had a phobia about driving.
I do it.
I've never enjoyed it.
Right.
But Lucid dreaming really helped me push past that.
Um,
and one of the ways was I was having this recurring nightmare.
This is not one,
it's in the book.
This is a bonus baby and there's a different nightmare.
I dealt with in the book.
Um,
I had this recurring dream that I would find myself outside the car,
but the car was,
but I was driving the car.
So there was like a me watching and then it me driving and I would rack because
I felt myself not in control of the car.
And so I finally had a lucid dream.
I got got lucid and realizes,
oh,
I mean in this fricking recurring dream and I kept crashing the car from this
distance and I would just rewind it and,
and try and get better control of it.
But I kept trying to get better control of it from a distance.
And so finally I just kind of Zap myself into the body that was driving the car,
the me that was actually driving the car.
It's like,
well shit,
I just need to drive the car.
I need to actually be behind the wheel.
Not In this disconnected way,
but in this present way.
I realize what the dream had been telling me.
How you purposely got involved in the idea of lucid dreaming for the book.
So how did you go about manifesting a lucid dream?
Okay,
so,
um,
I started researching the main guy who has studied lucid dreaming,
proved it was real and it holds for thing.
Doctor Steven Lubbers started reading his book and planning to go to Hawaii for
his 10 day workshop and I started convenient.
He has a 10 day workshop in Hawaii.
It's,
it's pretty cool.
I highly recommend vacation.
It's an incredible vacation.
And,
um,
and it's a vacation that tapped me into it,
like a whole new lingo of my life.
And so,
um,
it's the act of being aware.
You're dreaming while you're dreaming and choosing accordingly.
And the F I realized once I read that,
that I had woken myself up from nightmares for years.
And so it's like,
okay,
I have an opportunity to do something different here.
So there's different ways you can train for it.
One of them is you take the time to remember,
uh,
for instance,
a reoccurring dream or the dream you had last night.
Right?
I really recommend doing it with a recurring dream.
You remember it particularly a nightmare because those are so vivid.
You remember it,
it's like a meditation.
You meditate on it and you choose the point in the dream where you wish you had
become lucid,
where you wish you had gained control.
And so the,
the dream and the book that I had worked with was a dream where this creepy dude
shows up outside my house and he's peeking in through the window and eventually
I end up getting angry that he's trying to terrorize me.
And I opened the door and we would,
we would fight,
we would clash and I would wake up literally at times punching the air just
because I'm going after this guy.
So I decided to meditate on that dream and look for the spot within that dream
where I could,
uh,
get lucid.
And Gosh,
I'm not sure how long I at this point in,
it's in the book,
but I,
it was probably a couple of weeks of,
of work where maybe 10 minutes,
one day,
five minutes,
the next,
maybe the 15 minutes before I fell asleep one night.
And finally the dream happened.
And when the guys showed up in,
in,
uh,
my window,
I realized,
Shit,
this is,
remember this is the dream.
I'm dreaming.
And to feel yourself like,
to feel this.
You don't realize it until you've had a lucid dream,
but this youth,
there's a sense of disconnect between you and the in the u and the dream,
right?
Until you lucid dream and suddenly find yourself in this dream body,
you're,
you're no longer watching it like a movie.
You are in it and it's like the Matrix.
It just,
it's,
you get to be neo.
Suddenly the,
as I said before,
the laws of physics,
Plano part in,
most people find when they really begin,
when they first have a lucid dream,
there's this exhibit exhilarating sort of feeling
flying and dream sex.
Like those are the first things that people usually do this on.
Anybody wants to fly him?
Fuck yeah,
they banked some honey or they take off and it just lets you know that what is
what is best in life.
Conan was right,
he was right.
Everybody running around.
I just want support and have friends.
The Fuck Outta here.
What do you do when you're in your dream?
Did you make some friends?
No.
You fucking,
you fly.
I,
I have found that when I,
we're doomed when I don't,
when I don't have a plan in a lucid dream,
I spontaneously,
the first thing I think to do,
like,
because you can plan activities,
you can say I want to have a conversation with so and so.
I've had a lot of,
a fair amount of deaths in my family.
My Mom's Dad,
my oldest brother is dead.
A brother in law who was very much like a brother to me.
He was in the family since I was 12.
We shared a room together.
Uh,
he's dead.
I had two friends die of cancer.
Um,
and right around the time that the book where I was working on the book and um,
I wanted to see my mother again.
So I had a lucid dream in which,
you know,
I remembered that that's what I wanted.
And I called out into the dream,
show me my mother,
show me,
show me my brother,
show me my brother in law.
And suddenly I was in,
I was in the kind of like,
when the dream started,
I was in kind of like a mall and I got lucid because Leonardo Dicaprio showed up
and shoved me and I realized it's Fucking Weird,
leaner decapitation Oh,
I'm in a dream.
Right.
That's how I,
that's how I gained lucidity.
And um,
and I remembered what it was and I wanted to be there for,
and so when I called out,
show me my mother,
it was like the mall disappeared and there I was just in this black space.
And then my mom was there and this is years after she died.
I got to hug her and it felt every bit is real,
is really doing it.
I could feel her warm,
soft skin.
I could feel the bones under the skin.
I could smell her shampoo that she used on her hair,
that should,
I had not even thought of.
You know what I mean?
Like a,
that were memories of hugging my mother.
Um,
it's a beautiful,
beautiful experience.
And I,
I called for my brother and my brother and I,
they were there.
We ended up doing like kind of a group hug.
So it was really nice.
What do you think is going on when you're having a lucid dream?
I think you're dreaming,
right?
What's,
what is it allowing you to piece together this artificial reality?
You know,
they're not
Carly.
Um,
well,
what's allowing you to dream?
And we'll say,
here's the thing,
people think of
sleep as losing consciousness.
The fact is what you lose is awareness.
You're conscious because you're able to report what happened afterward.
Or at least most of us have some memory of,
of our dreams entering into another dimension.
So,
so dreaming is what happens in the absence of external input,
right?
We're not getting any external input anymore.
This is just our mind,
right?
Can we call that another dimension?
When you,
the dimension of imagination,
whatever the fuck that is,
however it exists in whatever,
whatever,
you know,
theater,
it plays out in theirs.
It's going on somewhere.
I mean,
whether it's just a bunch of firing inside
your head,
it's not really real.
At least inside your head.
There's a whole fake world.
Like what is that?
That's,
that's it.
That's the mystery of consciousness,
right?
That's the mystery of consciousness.
Where'd,
where does this experience really come from?
How could the neurons,
this three pound gelatinous mass secreting and emitting chemicals and electrical
firings create this in any,
the truth of this is that we don't fucking know.
And,
and yet we're inundated with people telling us what,
what we should consider important and,
and telling us at this point to just drilling us with this kind of materialist
paradigm that you,
that we are meet computers,
that we have no freewill.
All this sort of to me,
you know,
just sort of,
I don't buy that the no free will thing.
And I think if,
if they don't know how to explain it,
how am no free,
how we have freewill.
It's because we don't know yet enough about the brain and consciousness.
Um,
but,
and I love Sam Harris.
Sam Harris really turned me on to meditation through reading his book and I
consider him like sort of among the new atheists,
he is a breed apart.
I love the interview you did with him because he admits that the paranormals
been unfairly stigmatized and,
and all this sort of stuff.
But he's one of the guys out there trumpeting that we have no free will.
And I am really happy for the opportunity to talk about this because,
you know,
and he says rightly that a dogmatic religion has an unhealthy effect on,
on the psyche.
And it certainly does for a lot of people write it as a healthy on effect on
people in society.
Um,
because they're,
you know,
they're fearful,
they're judgmental of other people and all this sort of stuff.
But when you tell people they have no freewill,
they are more likely to cheat.
Umm,
and this has been researched,
right?
When you expose people to the idea that they have no free will and then you give
them an opportunity to cheat,
it's something they'll do it.
And if you tell people,
um,
uh,
was the other one,
oh,
they did this as games,
anything or it was a test.
It was an academic test and they cheated him,
cheat on an academic test because they were told they have no freewill.
So they were more Bo's idea that they most likely had no freewill.
And the control group who was not,
was not exposed to that information,
didn't cheat as much as the people who are anywhere near as much as the people
who had been exposed to the idea that we have no free will.
And when you say that Sam Harris believes that we have no freewill,
we should kind of does.
It's a very comprehensive sort of a take on things that has to do with not just
natural selection,
but the,
the,
the human organism itself and all the reward systems that are put in place to
motivate behavior.
It's a,
it's not like he believes that there's an architect that's guiding your life.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I just want to let everybody else,
you know,
when you say you have no free will,
like to,
for a lot of people with a religious,
exactly.
A fundamental idea and that's he's,
he's more,
he's looking at it completely the opposite from a scientific perspective.
The idea is that you're motivated constantly by a series of factors that are
beyond your control.
Theoretically,
if this is a completely just,
you know,
sort of a naturalistic material universe,
if we could measure all the variables from the big bang until now,
we could predict everything and you're going to do your entire life,
every choice you're going to make because it's all the result of the conditions
that that led up to it.
Yeah,
and other crazy idea once of taking a computer that's so powerful that you could
input in all of the data of everything in the state that it exists right now in
the world,
everything that exists in the world,
in the state that it exists right now,
and from that you could extrapolate and go back through time and get a full
detailed depiction of every single event that took place.
It sounds completely ridiculous right now,
but I don't think that's ridiculous in the future.
I think we're going to be able to get data from,
I'm like whoever thought like a million years ago,
you'd be able to get ice samples and that,
that was going to tell you a climate change,
you know,
from thousands and thousands a year.
And that's how we know what the fuck was going on 6,000 years ago.
You drill a gigantic chunk of ice and go,
well,
shit was different here and looking at a foot higher,
it's different here.
Yeah.
Um,
can I,
if I can take this back to lucid dreaming.
Yeah,
please.
So another way of,
and this is the part that really gets beneficial for your daily life.
The part that was most powerful for me in that sense.
Um,
the other way you can train yourself to have a lucid dream.
First of all,
you have to ask yourself the question,
how do you know when you're awake or when you're dreaming,
right?
How,
how do you know what's different and what a lubbers found and what everybody
else subsequently is found is that there,
there's this kind of state tests you can do to see which state you're in.
And the idea is to start doing it.
When you're awake,
do it all the time.
It should probably come from some Q and the environment.
If something odd happens where you just think,
oh,
that's strange,
lock into that.
Right?
And here's how you would do a state test.
Um,
print changes in a dream.
If you look at it,
something printed and then look away and then look back.
Um,
sometimes you have to do it a couple of times.
It,
it will change.
And the reason is because that print doesn't have any external reality.
It's something that your mind is producing a for you.
So,
um,
I had,
uh,
print at one point.
I usually,
I've just been able to figure out,
I just kind of lock into it and get,
okay,
this is a dream.
Like Leonardo Dicaprio,
push it,
push through and it was out in real life and all sudden you thought you were in
a dream.
She started fucking random people having sex with Leah.
What the fuck man?
I thought it was lucid dreaming.
Well this is why this is why you might want to do a state.
Yeah.
As well,
right?
Yeah.
And so you check print and you see if the print changed and I had print change
and to just um,
like symbols at 1.0 book just changed into a series of incomprehensible symbols.
Um,
digital clocks,
uh,
will really malfunction and machinery in general will not function because you
know,
you flip that light switch over there and it's actually connected to the light
bulbs.
But in the dream it's not
anything you flip the light switch and maybe the light goes on the first time.
Then when you turn it off it doesn't go off because it's not actually connected
anything.
Yeah.
I've had that happen in June was four where I realized it was lucid because I
couldn't turn the light switches on and off.
I've had that and so I realized,
Oh,
this is a lucid dream.
Like this is a dream.
Ed,
did you do anything with that?
Um,
you know,
when I started taking nootropics,
I had much more success with lucid dreaming.
I've found that my lucid dreams before where we're so fragile,
they were like a bubble,
like a child's bubble,
you know,
when they blow with those things.
But then once I started taking nootropics,
there were like a fucking volleyball and I was like hard,
you can kick it around like it was,
it was different.
He couldn't pop it.
I can't wait to take my on.
Yeah.
Any new tropics,
you know,
I obviously we sell on it products because they're the best that we can possibly
sell.
We sell the best shit we can sell.
But if you're not anyway,
for whatever reason,
if you're skeptical,
there's a lot of ingredients that the GRI ingredients are available online.
Take any of those and whether in conjunction or individually,
there's a lot of different companies and have them,
uh,
I've always talked about neuro one,
which is,
um,
Bill Roman [inaudible] stuff.
It's all theirs.
It's all fascinating stuff.
And you will have an increase in
brain functions.
So when you're doing a state test,
when you're,
when you're awake,
right?
One of the other things you do is you look for the behavior,
a strange behavior in the people that are around you.
And it's my whole life though.
When you're a comedian,
I'm going to dream and you'll,
you'll find,
you'll find that initially when you first start trying to do state tests,
when you're awake,
maybe the first day it feels really awkward because now you're,
I'm having a conversation with you,
but I'm also looking at the print on your shirt.
I'm looking down and then up and down and then up to see that it stays the same.
But after you get used to doing that.
And for me it only took a day,
day and a half,
you know,
something like that of doing a state test maybe eight or 10 times a day.
I found that my state tests were actually making me more aware and more mindful
of everything that was going on around me all the time and it,
and it seemed to have that effect of slowing my life down,
making be more considerate of,
of what's happening,
making me more present to the person that I'm with.
And suddenly I,
and I realized,
right,
like when Sam or somebody says,
we have no free will.
You know,
a lot of times we are just on autopilot.
We're just reacting.
How often do you eat a meal in?
Don't really taste it because you were busy and you were thinking about
something else.
Um,
when I started practicing lucid dreaming,
it was really,
it's a mindfulness practice.
I mean,
it hearkens back to the Buddhist practice of mindfulness.
You are just more aware of what's going on all the time.
I,
um,
saw a movie that gave me a great technique.
I forget what it was.
I think it was through the rabbit hole or one of those.
What the bleep movies are just overrun with fuckery.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's a lot of fuckery in those movies.
However,
even amongst fuckery you can sometimes get some,
get something you can use and one of them is in one of the videos the guy said,
when you come to a doorway,
knock on the door and say,
knock on the side of the door and say,
am I dreaming and do that during your waking hours?
Do that and go,
am I dreaming?
And I did it.
I walked up to a door and I said,
am I dreaming?
And there was nothing there.
I went,
Oh shit,
I'm fucking dreaming.
And then I went into the lucid dream,
but it was amazing how quickly it shifted over from just this random sleep and
dream state to just that one action of am I Jamie?
Holy Fuck,
I am dreaming.
And then there's the conscious mind.
Completely a rose inside of the dream.
Yes,
I can.
It didn't maintain it for very long.
I've still never been able to maintain it for very long.
I don't get it.
I don't get laid at all.
My dream.
It helps to have a good policy in my dreams.
It,
it helps to have a plan.
So,
so when you're thinking about,
you will,
you'll get there,
you'll get there.
I'm never felt I had been a man of faith.
You will get there if anybody will let you make a jerk off too much.
But,
but if you have a plan before you go to sleep,
if you've mentally rehearsed,
um,
just take 30 seconds to do it.
Two or three times a day.
If I have a lucid dream,
this is what I want to do.
You remember like I did with my mom?
I remembered because at first I was like,
Oh shit.
Okay,
I'm in this mall and you know,
like,
what am I going to have?
Like,
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I,
I can't,
you know,
tonight I had a mission.
I want to see my mother.
Right?
And so if you,
if you train for that,
you'll,
you will be able to,
um,
what if,
do you have nefarious intentions?
Go for it.
There's no,
you didn't know a lot.
Well go for it.
But maybe not because here's what's interesting,
right?
There's no laws,
Societal laws,
you know,
in,
in a dream,
right?
But you still have to deal with yourself in the morning.
And I know that sounds fucking funny,
but like I had a chance in one of my very,
very early lucid dreams to bang this dream hottie it was great.
This is the first one listed you my hat in Hawaii.
Me that you feel guilty when you woke up in the morning.
I didn't even do it because here's,
here's what happened.
I ended up,
um,
so I climb up into this building and I gained lucidity and um,
there was this woman in the room and I said to her,
and this happens a lot of times,
the dream characters,
I said,
I'm having a lucid dream.
I'm dreaming.
She's,
no,
you're not.
And they won't drink.
Characters will invariably tell you if you say to them,
this is not a dream,
they will invariably say to you,
no it's not.
And this is where the weirdest,
coolest parts of of lucid dreaming.
Cause even Lubbers right.
Eminent sort of scientist just kind of shrugs his shoulders.
Like somehow the dream world wants to maintain its,
its status as,
as real for you.
Right.
So the dream characters will say,
well this is not a dream.
Yeah.
And so I said to her,
no,
I'll prove it to you.
It's a dream.
And so I,
I turned and it was like,
you know,
you were talking before about when you have a subjective experience,
you still had the experience.
Right.
So I know totally what it's like to be fucking x man.
Because I said,
I'm gonna prove it to you.
And I turned and there were these big double doors,
like 30 feet away or something.
And I just went like this with a wave of my hand and the doors.
I said,
I'm gonna close these stores from here.
I went like this with my hand and the doors slammed shut.
And I was like,
Holy Shit at work.
Cause it was like,
well,
what am I first lucid dreams,
which was awesome.
And then I turned to her and I was like,
so now I'm going to have you.
Right.
And so I grabbed her and I went to kiss her and then I remembered because at
that point I was engaged to my wife,
right when I was like,
oh,
but you know,
I'm engaged in it felt so real again.
Her skin or the smell of her,
her,
it just,
I was a store.
He's got really good,
no,
you got to fuck that girl was supposed to [inaudible] you're getting dream
posey.
I am who I am.
Well,
you know what?
Maybe now even in your dreams,
I want you to be faithful to do that.
Wait,
let me tell you about my wife.
I gotta I gotta get my wife's back on this because when I told her about it
later,
she's like,
you could have done it immediately.
Just fucking take some Coleen and go right back in.
Well,
I'll just say this,
I've been doing,
uh,
other lucid dreaming since is that lots of good cover.
But that experimental clouds,
wait though,
there's something to think about here because one of the guys in the,
in the workshop who attended the workshop before I brought this up,
um,
in Hawaii,
he said,
you know,
he went to have sex with a dream character and the dream character refused him.
And his first thought is,
and this is just awful,
right,
was to commit dream rape.
Right?
And so he was going to force himself on this dream character and as he started
to do it,
he realized that this is not something he wanted because again,
Joe,
remember it feels real afterward.
It feels as real as anything you've ever done.
I mean,
you sound like you're having these very fragile dreams to begin with.
That happens.
I mean,
sometimes it takes a while to get it built up so that,
so that you're lucid dreams feel at least as real,
right?
Is this reality?
Do you want to carry it around the memory of raping somebody?
No.
Did I want to carry around the memory of cheating on my wife?
Well he's got shitty dreams cause in my dream I'm a pimp.
I just get pussy left him
this tech.
My problem is I wake up right before I put it in,
I get alone like,
oh yeah,
let's do this.
What?
I'm awake.
Fuck dammit.
That's bad news.
I have shot loads in my sleep so I'm sure it's happened.
I just haven't been lucid.
I never get lucid sucks.
But the girls are always nice to me.
No one's every angry at me,
you know?
And I never have like a lucid dream pitchers like yeah,
this is my dream.
Why are you so mean to me and my dream that's never happened luckily.
But yeah,
I mean I've never wanted to do anything creepy in my dreams anyway.
I've never wanted to do anything evil.
Right.
But I have fought crime.
Really have fought dragons and shit and my dream in a lucid dream.
Yeah.
Okay.
I listed dreams are really boring.
I'm like getting shit done like errands and like I remember this.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
Like knowing I've done a few lucid dreams before.
It's usually when I,
I'm,
I always feel it's like the level of your sleep cause I know it seems to happen
or you're right.
Yeah,
it's definitely the level your sleep.
If you're fucking exhausted,
you're not going to really put out a good one.
But we should do an experiment with the show.
Well we should all of us try.
We should try to have like,
you know,
have like someone who's going to come on again like Ari,
someone,
all of us tried to have a lucid dream.
I just force it and then see,
see what kind of progress we could make.
Because you have an m but you're not like trying to how I use a dre number one,
I'm flattered that you already know I won't be back.
What?
I said never let them already flooded that,
you know I won't be back.
No,
that's not what I meant.
I mean someone is here all the time.
Like I'm fucking like you live in Philadelphia,
sir.
You want to come back to the time you can come back to this.
That's not the spirit a little bit,
Brian,
real quick,
honestly.
So you've been an Olympic dream and if chosen to just carry out errands,
he just gives real everywhere.
He goes outside and she gets tackled and raped by big giant women that looked
like during our chrome comic books.
Big giant thighs,
giant acids.
They just hold them down and they just,
or women like this chair up in Boston and the fighter shoved his face into their
big meaty snatch.
Big fucking roast beef snatch,
big gigantic or rump roast,
big bullet wounds snatch and they just shove it in his face and then so he
doesn't leave the house much in his dreams.
Right?
Is that what you told me?
Yeah,
sure.
I fuck,
I have sex with a lot of ex girlfriends in my dreams.
I notice like I'll be like,
okay,
next,
come in,
come on in the room.
Lucid.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that'd be beautiful if you could just call it up.
Like if you had like a girl that likes to just do it,
not compatible with,
but God damn you guys had some awesome sex.
Like,
couldn't you just like,
honestly,
you can know
if you train it this long enough.
I mean I was able to,
you know,
quote manifest my mom,
right?
I mean we can manifest Brittany Spears or whoever it might bring me spears and
not now don't,
you know,
um,
I think,
uh,
I think that that idea of being able to do that,
it's fascinating and it's even more fascinating how few people pursue it.
Like,
you know,
yeah.
This is one of the sad parts of Steven [inaudible] story is that he discovered
this thing that you can really use,
um,
to defeat nightmares.
If you are those people who has night terrors where you wake up with like sleep,
I suffer from sleep paralysis or you have recurring nightmares or anxiety around
an event,
right?
You know,
you're going to be doing public speaking or something and maybe that's not your
bag.
You can rehearse.
Right?
And in,
in the dream.
So he's discovered and it's enriched my daily life.
I mean today I was doing,
I was just trying to train it again cause now I'm finally getting some sleep.
The boys are letting me sleep.
Right.
And so I'm starting to state test again and stuff and,
and I just look,
man,
I,
it just locks it locked me into my environment in,
in such a cool way.
I could suddenly really pick out the sound,
the leaves blowing in the wind and the,
you know,
is really interesting.
It was,
it was fantastic and detail how to do that in this.
I do know someone can do it if they want to follow it.
Yup.
And I use the,
I use the rehearsing a dream scenario and I use the state tests.
I get both those methods.
Don't forget the door knock folks.
Cause that shit work for me to say,
am I in a dream?
Well that's,
we'll have to get that during the day or the day time.
Also though,
don't you just do that during the day?
That would be so hilarious to see you walking around fucking knocking on doors
and every time you do it you go,
am I dreaming?
Okay,
then I'll do it.
I'll do it.
I just go [inaudible] then I'm dreaming.
There's no reason why heard it.
Good.
That's a good one as well.
Then also in trade pop up or Chinese people,
right?
Then you say Asians,
if you're in your dreams,
there's actually been really good research that,
um,
what we dreamed tends to be stuff we've been thinking about a lot in the last 24
to 48 hours.
So the whole principle of state testing and asking that question,
is this a dream?
Right?
Um,
or you know,
the way I always present my awake or am I dreaming?
Um,
the whole point of that is that when you do that regularly,
you're more likely to have that thought that arise while you are fucking
dreaming,
when you're really doing.
Yeah.
And it works.
That was the idea of the habit of knocking on the door that you'll,
they'll transfer that habit to your dreams.
The idea of dreams are so fucking fascinating.
There's so little we know about what the fuck is really happening and what kind
of weird imaginary world you're creating inside your mind.
And I love when people try to say,
well,
this means that you know,
the dragon represents,
you know,
you don't know what the fuck is talk,
I am in the Lord of the rings and I'm fighting a dragon.
It doesn't represent shit.
Yeah,
it represents,
I like watching wacky movies,
right?
So I got high and watched game of Thrones,
took five Alpha brains,
went to sleep and had a fucking dragon war.
Sometimes the cigar really is just fucking scar.
There are definitely times when you can say to yourself,
okay,
why this content,
right?
Why these images,
why these sounds?
Is there,
is there some message for me here,
something,
something my subconscious is and knowing on that I should be aware of and work
with in some way?
Well,
I'm sure there's a lot of things that occur in a dream or things that you're
fixated on and things that are constantly in your mind and that your imagination
will turn them into a dragon or a witch or a demon or,
or you know,
a vampire,
you know,
or a disease.
You know,
there's,
there's all sorts of things that you're terrified of.
And real life that you fixate on and much like the knocking on the door,
they just follow you and your dreams.
Yup.
And this gives you a chance to deal with them.
I mean,
if you approach something that's in a nightmare,
um,
more like a friend,
and that's weird to say,
but,
uh,
Lubbers did this with a,
this really ugly ogre that showed up on one of his dreams,
um,
that he would always recoil from.
Um,
he decided to,
uh,
we'll confront,
it's the wrong word because it sounds adversarial,
but he decided to approach it in a spirit of curiosity and compassion and like
figure out what's going on with it.
And I can't remember what exactly he said to it,
but he ended up,
he accepted it,
right?
He,
he,
he didn't recoil from it and it actually,
um,
if I remember correctly,
it became a part of him,
right.
He became a part of it.
Just kind of blended into him and he any,
any took that as a sign of,
Eh,
Mr Comedian,
take this on for size.
Right.
Dreams are about integration.
There are things we deny about ourselves and about our experience and they come
up in your dream because this is something you need to deal with and need to
look at.
And so if you do accept it in that way,
you end up feeling more empowered because instead of rejecting this thing,
your,
you're willing separately.
While I always thought that was fascinating,
when people give the very good advice of sleep on it,
you know something's bothering you,
sleep on it.
He goes that that there is something that happens to you during the dream state
where you have a better perspective in the morning.
I don't know what it is,
but I am a big proponent and sleeping on it.
I'm also a big proponent and jerking off before you make any decisions.
That's also very important.
I have to tell you,
man,
I hadn't experienced writing the book with a lucid dream where you can't imagine
the anxiety I had before writing it.
It was my first book.
Um,
I'd been writing for years and years and years,
but like,
you know,
5,000 word stories,
maybe a 7,000 word story.
Now I'm going to have to write fucking legit book in hardcover form.
I,
I'm going to have to write 90,000 words in 10 weeks.
And it was right before I was supposed to go get married.
And so there was no fucking with that deadline,
right?
I was going to have to write this thing and have a full good working draft of it
done in a 10 week period.
And I was having all sorts of anxiety over it.
And I ended up,
uh,
approaching a dream character in a store and I said to them,
I,
I need help.
And she's like,
we need help with.
And I said,
well,
I'm writing a book.
And she said to me with the utmost sort of compassion and sincerity,
she said,
the book is already written.
And I had from that the feeling of,
you know,
there's just not,
well,
you,
you've worked on creative projects at the time.
There's nothing like having finished and knowing it's right and it's good.
And I had that feeling just sort of flood into me when,
when she said this so real and so vividly that when I woke up I started thinking
about all the vagaries of how time works and all this sort of stuff.
And then you know,
in a sense the book is already written.
I'm just going to live through the period of writing it and it just totally
reframe the experience of writing that book for me.
And in a strange sort of way,
I mean to say that I wrote the book and an altered states,
it is a big powerful statement in a way.
I did.
I never had less anxiety about writing anything in my life.
I would wake up seven seven 30 in the morning and was completely on lean from
work.
I would get a cup of coffee,
I'd be writing within 15 minutes of waking up instead of producing what my goal
was,
which is around 1500 words a day.
I was regularly writing 300050008000 there were days I wrote over 10,000 words
in one day I would finish at two 30 or three I would eclipse my fucking goal by
miles.
I would finish at two 30 or three I would go out and buy fresh groceries and a
bottle of wine and when my wife would get home,
I'd beat as joyful friar standing there making her this like a delicious dinner
and totally enjoying my life.
Like rocking balls.
Right.
It was,
it was awesome.
And um,
and it was lucid dreaming that did that and it was that experience of having
that anxiety taken away from me in this really vivid,
a real way.
Having those really fascinating.
It was awesome.
I wonder if we could get people are in on this one.
If we get people to just start trying to lucid dream there is the resources
online.
Besides your book,
would you recommend people checking out?
You can go to Steven [inaudible] website.
Do you say his name?
Laberge a l a,
B.
E r.
G.
E.
And he has a website.
Steven laberge.
Yeah,
just search.
I can't remember what the addresses for it.
Um,
his book is,
is really phenomenal.
It's,
it's very scientific,
but it's for the,
you know,
anybody can read it and pick it up.
So I mean there
it's become the Bible for what they call themselves on iron odds for people who
lucid dream regularly.
Um,
I want to say some about my book by the way.
It is right now.
They,
they,
um,
it's back listed,
which means they're no longer,
they're not completely ignoring it,
but it's been out for a couple of years.
So they're not pushing it.
And once they,
one of the things they do with a blacklisted book is they'll price it down to a
dollar 99 on kindle for a couple of weeks and jack up the sales figures.
Right.
And so I asked them in advance of the show,
could you please leave it?
Cause they just did it recently.
I was like,
please leave it at a dollar 99 for the show.
And they said,
no.
But I woke up this morning and Brian,
I guess has got up now.
It's still a dollar 99,
please.
I don't get fucked up.
What's it supposed to?
They fucked up but good because,
eh,
my,
it's nine 99 normally,
but my feeling is let's just get it into people's hands.
And so right now let's all engage in an act of piracy.
Harper Collins fucked up.
Get out there and get the book for a buck 99.
I love it.
And I hope they look,
I hope they change their minds.
It's possible that the person I talked to ended up running up the flagpole and
decided,
you know what,
we should leave it at this price.
I don't really know,
but I know what they told me it was an unequivocal no,
but here it is still a dollar 99,
but he's found it.
I'll get it for 11 bucks.
That's a hardcover.
Oh,
the hardcover.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well that's great man.
Don I know is very reasonable and I,
I get all my books through.
Um,
uh,
I have one of those,
I have a kindle and I have a,
um,
I love it.
The book to Barnes and noble version of it.
Any book,
any magazine,
I suddenly feel the impulse to,
to read.
It's there.
And when my tablet,
instantly,
you know,
we live in strange times,
man.
The ability to get those,
you get a book like that off of Wifi and some of them even have three g
connections.
It's like walkie fucking times for publishing.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I think,
a lot of people are getting their books that way now.
Right.
What is your,
do you know what the percentage of Ebook to regular buckets,
what you're selling?
I know this book is outselling,
um,
from the time it was released,
it's way more electronic and more than the general industry.
So when this first came out in a year and a half,
two years ago or whatever it is,
it was,
I think they told me the figure was like 50 low,
50% higher for electronic books.
This book was over 60% electronic books.
And I'm answering what that says,
but,
well,
it's the,
the friends subjects are really supported by the Internet,
Internet websites and all the nuttiness.
Um,
w there's a bent spoon on the cover.
Can people bend spoons with their brain.
You know,
I wanted to get to the bottom of that and it's an immersion journalist.
I actually was waking up in the morning and trying to bend a fucking spoon,
right.
Really with my head.
And I did it I think three days in a row where,
um,
I think the first thing I wanted to go 15 minutes and I just started feeling so
silly after seven or eight that I stopped.
And then on day two,
you know,
I think I did three or four minutes on day three of like staring at the spirit
for like 45 seconds.
And I was like,
I can't do this.
I cannot do this.
Maybe if you like one of those monks on a mountain dude to stare at that spoon
for days and days and days it goes like this.
All right.
Just imperceptibly,
I've had some people that respect tell me they think it's real and that I
couldn't do it because I couldn't do it because I wasn't taking it.
People leaving it hot water,
you respect them because they can kick your ass.
That's one reason to respect somebody.
That's where the intersection of a lot of money,
the met along the way,
who haven't stuck their neck out on this publicly,
um,
because it's,
it's really fraught,
man.
I mean,
the guy who popularized it or he'd Geller is,
um,
you know,
in my first amendment protected opinion because he's fairly to just,
um,
a magician.
So,
and so it's a very controversial subject.
This is one of the places that James,
Randy kind of made his bones.
The skeptic in a debunker was going after rate Gellar and so a lot of people
just don't want to be publicly linked to this subject,
even if they believe in it.
And so I met some people like that who have never publicly spoken about it.
Um,
but they're,
you know,
they're doing incredible stuff in the world and they,
um,
they claim that they were able to do it or they,
you know,
they were at a quote,
spoon bending party.
There's some people that the been throwing parties,
grab it here.
I'm gonna have my spoon right up your ass.
Ain't no spoon bending party.
You know what [inaudible] Gardy,
I got to say all those guys would pass on on the million dollar prize that he's
offering.
You know,
the million dollar prize is Randy's million dollar prize.
The bullshit.
I'm not into it.
I mean,
I,
I think that they did not end up in his since idea prize.
The people who are doing incredible Perez psychology don't fit in to the way the
prize works.
So like people like Dean Raden and Rupert Sheldrake and when Sam was on here,
he about Rupert and said there's something very fishy about not going after the
million.
Right?
There's really not because,
and,
and I love Sam,
but I just think that maybe he,
again,
we all come at this with a worldview and he's probably a little more predisposed
to be on the material side of things.
Right?
And,
and,
um,
but,
but um,
Sheldrake or or Dean Raden or any of these guys,
Daryl Bem,
they're going to construct a study that requires dozens,
if not a hundred subjects that will take an hour and a half for their each
individual session conducted over weeks,
months,
or a year to get like this Ganzfeld effect at 32% versus 25% right.
That we started this whole thing with and James Randy is going to need,
needs an event that will take place with a very small sample size where you'll
get like 10 bites at the apple,
basically 10 chances to get something or 12 in an afternoon or an evening.
It is apples to oranges.
It is completely in a clickable to what credible Paris psychologists are doing.
So the idea that Rupert Sheldrake hasn't taken it up is not only not very fishy,
it tells you that he has some,
some fucking sense.
So in order to get Randy's money,
you have to do something like make the empire state building disappear.
You can do something.
Yeah.
And you have to do it in a small,
the big thing is you have to do it in a small sample size.
I mean,
statistical segment significance is generated by sheer repetition,
right?
And so when you're in a rand,
Randy requires a small sample size to approve.
He doesn't specifically require a small sample size,
but whenever you look at any of the studies they're doing,
they're doing,
they're doing stuff that takes,
again,
you know,
an afternoon or an evening.
And it's a kind of a public event.
And I,
and I,
again,
I mean there are some pair of psychologists,
um,
think his name's Dick Biermann who said he approached him and couldn't work.
Anything else,
super grateful,
uh,
approached me and couldn't work anything out.
Daryl bem apparently thought about it and,
and realize that with the,
within these parameters,
the kind of research he's doing,
the kind of effect size he's trying to take to get the time it would take him to
generate that just doesn't really fit into what they're doing over there.
What seems to me that that statistical 32% is,
that's a real number.
It's 7% difference is legit.
I mean it would seems like that's something that has to kind of be looked at
now.
It should be,
I would agree with you.
It should be.
But I think that this sort of the professionals and,
and look,
they're professional skeptics like French and why has been the guys that I
mentioned before who will engage in a,
in a,
in a reasonable conversation about this,
but then they're skeptics to me like the j Raf,
the James Writing Educational Foundation,
those guys who are or are just kind of rejecting it out of hand.
But there's really something,
there is something to,
to look at here.
There's something to wonder about and I find that,
you know,
uh,
number one,
more fucking accurate way of looking at it and which is great.
Right?
And it's also a far more interesting world than the tiny percentage bump is
really fascinating because it really makes
you go,
oh,
maybe it is an emerging skill or maybe it is an emerging sense or as you said
before,
declining one because we don't,
we don't use it in the,
the natural yeah.
World anymore and don't cultivate it at all.
And in,
look,
you know,
it's,
it's a figure when you look at that,
like the canceled affect 32 versus 25,
you know,
or whatever an individual study might show,
right?
Um,
one of the things that's powerful about that figure,
and it speaks to one of the things the skeptics do well,
right,
is they warn you away from those people who really are con artists,
right?
The idea of the Super Psychic John Edwards,
Sylvia Brown,
there is threadbare,
uh,
evidence for that.
It's not something that I would put my name on and reputation on is saying
there's something we really need to look at this,
right?
But the Ganzfeld effect,
there's so many studies,
dozens and dozens of studies that,
that go into these,
what they call these men analyses when they crunch all the numbers together that
I will put my name on and say,
you know what?
We should fucking look at that.
Right?
And,
and so it's not that the skeptics are,
are all wrong or all wet,
right?
But they paint with far too broad a brush.
And I think at the end of the day,
my,
my own guests and their motivation is the fact that that mechanism would be
unexplained.
The fact that that mechanism would suggest there is more to us than meat is not
something that won't acknowledge.
Because when you really look at these people,
when you look at Randy,
he's also a dogmatic atheist.
The idea that we're more than meets starts to introduce the idea of a soul,
right?
Something that will transcend this bodily death.
And the idea that we have to,
uh,
you know,
worry about that to some degree and govern our behavior based on what we're
going to become leader or what we're going to have to deal with later
potentially.
And so I think that they're kind of keeping the barn door shot,
right?
They've taken on this tack in life,
um,
that they're going to hold this shit down,
that fringe ideas,
the unexplained anything,
a cult,
what have you.
Yeah.
All those things are just,
yeah.
Not to be,
not to be given any,
any power,
but it's kind of unscientific to block out anything,
isn't it?
Yes.
The I,
the idea of science is to observe everything.
Yeah.
Even very infrequent,
but possibly real events.
Yes.
Yeah.
And you're a fucking scientist evoke.
You're a scientist.
God dammit.
And the book is a fringe Ologie and it sounds fucking awesome man.
I'm,
I'm going to get into this dude,
thank you very much for coming on the podcast.
Thanks for getting the book and thanks for telling them to keep it at a dollar
99 which you can get it right now.
I just want to say one more thing.
I just can see this.
All the interviews I've done now,
and I've done a ton of them.
This was the biggest honor.
And the reason is because I've been listening to this podcast for the last
couple of years now,
like year and a half or more.
And I find,
and it's so,
it's funny,
I'm not sure any guests you've had on in this position where this show is become
part of the way I reinforce my own good habits.
Like I find that it,
it just keeps me motivated.
It keeps me focused on,
I think of there's podcasts ultimately,
secretly it's kind of a cloak and dagger enterprise to get people to live their
best possible life.
And that's the function it performs for me.
And so being on your show,
fucking Jack
to be here.
So thank you brother.
I really appreciate it,
that man,
it means the world to me and uh,
I really appreciate you coming on here to,
uh,
to share your thoughts and have a cool conversation with us and enhance the
podcast and become a part of podcast history.
You're dirty fucks.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
we've got a lot going on this week.
We got a,
tomorrow we'll go bring it on.
Adam Hunter,
we've got Duncan Trussell this week we got our sheer fear and this Friday I am
at the Ice House on uh,
the in the big room on at eight 30 and 10 32 shows,
uh,
this Friday at the Ice House.
And there's also a show going on in the little room at the same time.
Right?
We've got this,
you don't have a show going on over there.
Okay,
well Brian will be on my show to you unless you got something to do.
Got to see what are you doing?
Alright.
Um,
next week steeper.
Now those coming back on the podcast as well as uh,
Jimmy Smith.
We moved Jimmy to a next week.
Jimmy who is the,
uh,
he does what I do for Bella tour.
Very cool guy.
We're going to have some,
uh,
so all you people going wound talk more [inaudible] stove,
all news quick go shit.
Those people will be fulfilled next Tuesday.
So tomorrow is Adam Hunter and a,
if you want to follow Steve Volk on Twitter,
it's Steve v o l k.
And uh,
the book is fringe Ologie and it is available as we said right now on amazon.com
you fuck heads and uh,
I say that with all love.
Thank you to a thank you to kerosene games for a sponsoring the podcast.
Go pick up blades slinger.
It is available right now for $2 and 99 cents.
How do you go wrong there?
You don't,
you fucks.
Okay.
You don't go to onnit.com o.
N n I t use the code named Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
anything more to say?
The nice kids before we get out of here,
Brian,
uh,
we're going to be at,
I'm going to be at Avn with a Sam Tripoli,
and then it's about to be announced.
Oh,
you're not supposed to tell anybody.
You suppose you just fucking,
you just blew your own press release.
How dare you.
That's how much he loves you folks.
He violated all of his confidentiality agreements and just went,
yeah,
I've been talking about doing a show in Vegas for last week.
Are you?
Or what's supposed to tell people about this?
But I didn't tell you what it is.
Yeah,
you just fucking threw a god.
Aaa is about the announcement on tonight's 97 think.
Oh,
well,
there you go.
You,
you,
you fucking beautiful humans.
We'll see you guys tomorrow.
Maybe.
I don't know what you're doing.
I mean,
you don't have to listen every time.
Not Needy or nothing.
All right.
See Ya.
Love Ya.
Love the fuck out of Hollywood.
Ooh.